um
all right
thank you so
much today
how are you
hello
good morning i know
[Music]
yeah
okay
all right are we ready for the jury
yes your honor
okay
good
um
good morning ladies and gentlemen
all right did we see your next witness
um
good morning your honor uh mr depp calls
kate moss to the stand
she will be appearing on your screen all
right ma'am can you hear me
yes can you count to five for me
one two three four five
thank you ma'am if you could raise your
right hand
do you swear for him to tell the truth
under penalty of law
okay thank you
good morning miss moss or i should say
good afternoon your time your time uh my
name is ben chu from the firm of brown
rudnick
would you please state your full name
for the record
kate smuss
miss moss where do you reside
london england
from where are you testifying today miss
moss
um gloucestershire england
miss moss do you know johnny depp
yes i do
how do you know mr depp
i had a relationship with him
uh did there come a time when you and mr
depp had a romantic relationship
yes
for how long ms moss were you and mr
depp a romantic couple
from 1993
to
1994 to 1998.
miss moss did there come a time when you
uh while you and mr depp were a couple
that the two of you took a vacation
together
to the golden eye resort in jamaica
yes
what if anything happened when you were
in jamaica with mr depp
i um
we were leaving the room
and johnny left the room before i did
and there had been a rainstorm
and as i left the room i slid down the
stairs
and i hurt my back
how did you
i apologize ms moss please continue
and i screamed because i was in because
i didn't know what happened to me and i
was in pain and um
he came
running back to help me
and carried me to my room and got me
medical attention
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
miss moss have you ever before today
testified in any kind of court
proceeding
no i have never
why did you decide to testify today
objection your honor
all right that's beyond the scope of
what we just talked about
all right i'll sustain the objection
thank you miss moth uh we have nothing
further at this time we greatly
appreciate your taking the time
to testify any cross-examination no your
honor all right you're free to go thank
you ms boss thank you very much
all right your next witness
your honor we're calling dr shannon
curry
just give us a moment
to move the tv
all right dr curry
good morning mr jensen good morning
please call shannon curry dr shannon
curry that's fine ma'am you're still
under oath so
please have a seat doctor
good morning
good morning dr craig good morning
can you remind the jury who you are and
what you do sure
i'm dr shannon curry i'm a clinical and
forensic psychologist and i'm here today
to rebut the testimony that was provided
by dr hughes
which of the opinions rendered by dr
hughes do you intend to rebut
so they're generally speaking there are
three main categories that i'd like to
talk about today
so the first is that
dr hughes misrepresented the tests and
the results that she utilized in her
evaluation
she misrepresented my testing and the
results that i obtained in my evaluation
and she communicated in a man in a
manner provided testimony in a manner
that presented
essentially her own opinions and the
self-report of ms heard as facts
okay the first category you talked about
was the misrepresentation
of her own test methods and results what
do you mean by that
so uh dr hughes used she stated that she
administered 12 tests
in actuality she used eight checklists
about half of those were symptom
checklists the other half were
checklists checklists about
experiences that people can have with
domestic violence and those are not
appropriate for forensic settings they
are easily exploited
other issues that you intend to address
relative to
misrepresent misrepresentation of own
results yes so in addition to using
these checklist measures which are
easily exploited in a forensic context
they're developed for research or
treatment only
she also stated that these checklists
revealed things that they simply cannot
reveal especially in this context
and let's see
she also misrepresented
clear indications on several of the
objective measures that she offered
and there were indications visible that
ms heard had essentially
engaged in what we call response
distortion so
clear indications of exaggeration on one
of the measures that's specific to ptsd
clear minimization
of symptoms intentional on another more
broad personality and psychopathology
based measure that she gave to ms heard
which she did not acknowledge
did you
intend to address anything relative to
the caps five
i did so
dr hughes administered the caps five
about 10 days after i did almost two
years after she
initially tested ms hurd
and she did not administer the test
appropriately so she left
major components blank she didn't apply
the scoring rules that are clearly
outlined with the test
and yet she diagnosed her misheard with
ptsd based on that assessment
what about
dr hughes's use of the personality
assessment inventory
so
of the tests that dr hughes administered
two would be considered of those twelve
two would be considered what we call
forensically relevant instruments
meaning that they're objective enough
and they provide us with some
information about how the examinee
approached the test that it would be
appropriate for this setting where the
examinee is going to have a natural
incentive to present themselves in a way
that benefits the outcome of their case
now on the pai there were clear
indications that
ms heard was responding and obtained
scores in a manner that's consistent
with individuals who have a personality
disorder and there was also an
indication that
several scales we call this a
configuration so you might have one main
scale that you notice is elevated then
you look for additional subscale
information to get additional
information on what could be elevating
that scale
and there was a configuration that
showed that even though ms heard had
moderately elevated one of the skills
that can be associated with trauma
that elevation is better explained by
childhood or distant traumatic
experiences like the complex trauma
misheard reported experiencing growing
up
okay
you um you
that
that
dr hughes utilized checklists that are
not appropriate
for forensic analysis can you explain
that
yes so as i said um in any sort of
forensic context whether it's a civil or
criminal matter
a person who's being evaluated is going
to have major incentive to present in a
way that benefits the outcome of their
case
so you always approach the examination i
believe dr hugh said with the health
healthy
dose of skepticism but that alone is not
enough we have to operationalize that so
we actually have to administer very
comprehensive objective tests that
either control
for attempts to manipulate the test
results or reveal attempts to manipulate
the test results so that we're not just
blindly accepting the results
or the self-report of the examinee
how many tests were
administered by dr hughes
she said that she administered 12 tests
how many of them uh were appropriate for
forensic physical examination
so the trauma symptom inventory is
appropriate it's an objective measure
and it does have two primary scales that
look at how the person approached the
test the personality assessment
inventory is an excellent test it is a
broadband measure meaning that it
captures not only symptoms of mental
illness but also general personality
traits
that also gives us pretty detailed
skills similar to that one test i
administered mmpi that tells a lot of
nuanced information about the way the
person approached the test
she also administered a malingering
screen that can be very very useful but
not in this context
so it's called the miller forensic
assessment symptom test
it's a brief set of questions that you
ask the examinee and it's been shown by
research to be extremely effective at
identifying and examine these attempts
to fake a severe mental illness or
psychosis and psychosis is when somebody
loses complete connection with reality
it's excellent for that purpose it's
actually been shown in the research to
not be effective at all for identifying
a respondent's attempts to fake ptsd
anxiety or mood disorders the questions
are just too odd for somebody who has
the wherewithal to be trying to have
ptsd to endorse they they see through it
so she used that
um that's a fine test but not
appropriate for this context
of the various tests that she
administered how many were these
checklists eight of them
and
what are you talking about specifically
okay
so
i had mentioned that there were two main
categories of checklists she used the
first is the symptom checklists
those included the bet depression
inventory it's a brief inventory of
items that essentially show all of the
symptoms of depression that a person
might have and you rate which
level of severity you have for each
question she also gave the back anxiety
inventory very similar but just with
questions about anxiety she gave the
mood disorder questionnaire which is a
very brief again checklist it shows
symptoms of bipolar disorder bipolar
disorder is a mood disorder where you
might have an extended manic episode and
then a very extended depressive episode
and then she gave the post-traumatic
stress disorder checklist
and that is a screening instrument only
it
contains every single symptom of ptsd
so there's a secondary danger here too
when you think about it
given that ptsd is the most frequently
feigned and claimed diagnosis in civil
courts
if you're handing somebody a checklist
that lists every single symptom of ptsd
you're essentially teaching them all the
little nuances that we're looking for to
give that diagnosis so she gave that to
ms hearn
miss heard endorsed most of the items
and dr hughes diagnosed her with ptsd
and substantiated that opinion
by ms herds checking those items on the
pcl5
um
were there another group of chess
checklists that dr hughes used yes so uh
she also oh and i forgot one on the last
because i don't think of it as one but
previously i'd explained and i do not
expect you to remember it's called the
life events checklist which is just an
inventory of experiences a person may
have gone through that are traumatic dr
hughes also used that and that's
appropriate to use before the clinician
administered ptsd scale the gold
standard caps five however she
administered this long ago before she
gave the caps five um now that going on
to the second group there were three
checklists that she gave that are
specific to abuse
and the first she gave the danger
assessment scale was actually developed
for use by nursing staff in an emergency
room setting specifically for female
victims of intimate partner violence the
purpose of this is important because our
forensic ethics our psychology ethics
talk a lot about relevance is the test
relevant to the purpose and the danger
assessment scale its initial purpose is
completely different this was developed
to show high risk factors for
dangerousness and pretty much to help a
female who is in an extremely abusive
partnership who is in the emergency room
with extreme injuries
to
stop rationalizing because if she has to
check off all the things that have
happened that year that have been
dangerous does he own a gun has he you
know i won't go into all of them but
the more she checks off the more likely
it is that she might realize that she is
in imminent danger and then accept
resources offered by the hospital and
social work to protect her that was the
purpose of this scale it was never
intended to be used as a retrospective
measure to look back in time
and find out whether abuse was occurring
based on one person's report years later
in a litigation
she also gave the conflict tactic scale
revised the second edition
similarly this scale was developed for
research purposes to research family
violence
again there is no control for
exaggeration or minimizing it was just
given to research participants
anonymously so that we could get data on
the prevalence of abuse and how abusive
dynamics work and on that there's 39
questions where the respondent indicates
essentially certain abusive behaviors
they may have engaged in and then 39
where they indicate behaviors their
partner might have engaged in and
obviously you can understand that in a
forensic setting the respondent is
likely to put a very minimal amount of
behaviors they engaged in and then
extremely uh
increase the number of behaviors their
partner might have
um and then lastly let's see i oh the
abusive behaviors observation checklist
was the third checklist she gave
this one
has not there's there's no known
research even on its effectiveness for
what it was developed it's a theoretical
very brief checklist
that was meant to be used for therapy
where an individual who had experienced
domestic violence
could
essentially read through some of the
behaviors that constitute violence that
they might not have been aware of
and if those behaviors applied to them
or if some of those coping strategies
where ones they utilize they would check
that off and then they have a way to
talk about it because now it's been put
towards again this is similarly
problematic
if you're in a civil litigation the
person's motivated to have their results
be consistent with a claim or an
allegation of intimate partner violence
and an allegation that they've been
severely harmed then they could simply
just check off more and not only that
but checklists like this one
specifically give a lot of nuanced
information about what clinicians might
be looking for
when they're assessing
whether violence was present or whether
the person's self-report is consistent
with a genuine self-report of having
been victimized they're given all that
information that we might be looking for
can you talk specifically about dr
hughes's use of the i think you called
it the pcl5
yes
so the pcl5
is the post-traumatic stress disorder
checklist this is different not to be
confused with the caps 5 which i've
talked about previously as being the
gold standard
the pcl5 was developed by the national
center ptsd it's intended for treatment
so if i were for instance working with a
service member who i know had
been in combat
i would probably give this as a standard
with my intake before we do the
diagnostic interview it kind of gives me
a read on how somebody who's there for
treatment who we assume can be taken at
their word because
if they give us correct information
they're going to get an appropriate
treatment and if they give us incorrect
they might not get the treatment they
need
so
i would give this checklist to them and
then if they recognize some of those
symptoms of ptsd they could check it off
and that would probably indicate to me
that i need to then do the next step if
they're checking off
more items than not i would probably
decide to administer the
clinician-administered ptsd scale that
gold standard interview to find out more
about a diagnosis
the last thing is what everybody refers
to is the caps five
yes the caps five
all right what about
um well you talked about forensic use
what do you mean by that
so when i'm talking about uh forensic
evaluation that's an evaluation that
doesn't isn't done for therapy or
treatment it's specifically to assist
the fact-finder to assist the judge or
the jury in the court by providing
information about the psychological
status about an individual and that's an
important delineation too we are not
psychologists i wish we remind readers i
wish we had a crystal ball and could
find out whether intimate partner
violence occurred and look back in the
past but it's nothing like that really
it's a lot less interesting we look at
data we have to control for those
response biases and then we also are
looking at functioning
which
is really the bottom line of the
assessment did the person have a change
in functioning from before the alleged
trauma or in this case the alleged ipv
to after is there a decline in the way
they're going about their lives
all right
dr curry um
let's look back at uh
some of those domestic violence
checklists that you were talking about
okay
and um
did you see any problem with the use of
those
yes
what problems did you see
well
uh doctor first of all they shouldn't be
used so we do have professional
standards that require that we utilize
instruments that are relevant and
appropriate for the particular setting
and that we substantiate our opinions
based on data that is reliable from
tested accurate reliable tests for the
purpose um so there's that it's
inconsistent with the ethics um and
essentially they they just shouldn't be
used they don't provide us with the
robust information that it would be
expected in such a high stakes setting
would you have expected dr hughes to
comment on the
limitations of the checklist she was
using yes so
first of all
uh dr hughes provided opinions based on
these checklists so she referenced
especially the danger assessment scale
several times throughout her testimony
uh stating that ms hurd was in a very
dangerous situation
we also have an ethical guideline and a
professional standard as well that
indicate that whenever there is question
about the reliability and the validity
and in psychology we use the term
validity to talk about accuracy
of any of the methods that we're using
to
collect data
we
clearly communicate not only that there
are limitations to our opinions but we
also need to provide the fact finder
with information about what the
potential implications or impact could
actually be so
for instance if we use a scale
that's idiosyncratic for the purpose but
we would first need to explain why we
made that decision to not follow
standard procedures
and then we would need to explain the
use of this skill might
introduce some potential
exaggeration of this symptom and and so
i'm trying to control for that that way
but that was one of the limitations of
my opinion you have to make it very
clear transparency is really at the
center of good science in general
um
you talked a little bit about
ignoring response distortion what is
response distortion
response distortion is a term that
speaks generally about
an examinee approaching a test and
providing answers that are either
exaggerated or minimized but in some way
an inaccurate representation of their
current mental status or their
experience
what test do you believe that dr hughes
failed to acknowledge response
distortion on
so uh
she administered the personality
assessment inventory which is similar to
the test i gave them mmpi too it's that
general broadband measure of
psychopathology symptoms
and personality traits it includes
several scales
that are very good at detecting either
exaggeration minimization or even trying
to claim that you have unusually good
qualities
on that test
there were clear indicators that ms
heard very similar to the way she
approached my mmpi engaged in
defensiveness
and in fact there's a function that you
can look at so you have that main scale
elevation we call it positive impression
management was elevated and then
because we want to make sure that
somebody isn't elevating that scale just
because they have such well-being
there are additional configurations of
scales that you can look at to find out
what's going on and so the casual
discriminant function is
uh sort of the name of one of these
configurations these uh equations that
are done
and she was highly elevated on that um
in fact that elevation tells you that no
this isn't accidental this isn't because
she's just doing so well in life that
she has an extremely extremely low
amount of problems no this is an
intentional over reporting or i'm sorry
an intentional
effort to minimize
any
uh
appearance of having problems
now you may have addressed this but
there was a reference to malingering
yes so what's interesting about ms
heard's approach to different tests is
that it seems to be influenced by
what we call the face validity of
questions on the test so if a test looks
like it's measuring ptsd
you see exaggeration on her validity
scales if the test has less face valid
questions for instance the personality
assessment which dr hughes administered
them mmpi 2 which i administered where
she can't quite figure out what the
questions are asking they seem really
banal in general on those you see
extreme defensiveness minimization of
any potential pathology essentially
presenting herself as perfect and free
of any mental illness or personality
disorder but on the trauma symptom
inventory which dr hughes administered
um
that was the one that i previously
indicated for ease of explanation when
the test results come out for how the
person approaches the test that test
itself prints it as a percentage
and there's a really excellent scale
for finding out if a person is
exaggerating their symptoms of ptsd it's
called the atypical response scale
and the tsi2 is the revised version of
this test and that scale was improved
this time around to really
try to be a clean indication of is this
person exaggerating
and it it puts quite high questions in
the test that are so unusual they might
sound like ptsd but even the most severe
cases of ptsd
don't have these symptoms
and so somebody who's intentionally
trying to exaggerate ptsd or possibly
unintentionally but
nonetheless who's exaggerating it is
likely to endorse these items even
though they're not real ptsd symptoms
miss heard sports so highly on this that
even if there is although dr hughes
correctly said there tends to be a
negative skew when people have the high
levels of distress that's associated
with ptsd so sometimes people score
higher on this even when they do have
ptsd she scored so high that that is
effectively ruled out as a possibility
okay
what
about dr hughes's
administration and use of the caps five
okay yes so dr hughes had diagnosed miss
heard with ptsd back in 2019 when she
began testing her it wasn't until two
years later more than two years later
ten days after i administered the caps
five with ms heard that dr hughes held
an impromptu evaluation session remotely
with ms heard and administered the caps
five she had previously diagnosed ptsd
without using what we consider to be the
gold standard ptsd diagnostic interview
and
again when we're doing a forensic
evaluation it is an important
responsibility and part of our ethics
and professional standards are that we
document
everything to allow for transparency and
full judicial scrutiny
and
dr hughes
administered incorrectly she left
huge sections very relevant sections
blank there's no
way to understand why she scored it as
high as she did based on the information
that's provided you're essentially
supposed to notate the
examinees responses as verbatim as
possible to explain your reasoning and
implying their scoring procedure it's a
standardized test and if you don't
follow those standard procedures it's
completely invalid
not only that
but af it looks as though
dr hughes further invalidated it by
trying to
show that she had assessed for the
childhood trauma impact and it's
she had said that she went back and
asked the childhood
question but you can't do that if you're
assessing for two separate periods of
one's life to find out the relatedness
to ptsd you do two separate caps
interviews period you don't create your
own question system that is non-standard
administration of the test and it
invalidates it
all right um you also mentioned
with respect to the pai or the
personality assessment inventory
that dr hughes failed to mention uh
some elements
what she failed to mention
oh okay so on the personality assessment
inventory so first she failed to mention
that there was it were clear indications
of response distortion
she also failed to mention
that
ms heard scored in
her score profile against their main
scores she did elevate a score
for the borderline personality disorder
sort of section but that in and of
itself would not indicate a diagnosis
however the configuration of her scores
overall
is consistent with that and in fact it's
one of the diagnostic suggestions given
by the test itself
and then also there's a configuration
around misheard's trauma responses on
that particular test which demonstrates
that it is more likely that those
symptoms were reported in relation to
something in the distant childhood it's
more consistent with childhood chronic
abuse than present circumstances or
recent circumstances
okay i think you said in addition to
the
the issues with their own testing
dr hughes misrepresented your results
she did
can you tell us how
so what i would say the main issue was
that she said that ms hurd obtained a
normal profile on my mmpi too
all right how do you disagree with uh dr
hughes relative to the profile okay
so the profile was not normal so ms hurd
already had
subtle elevations
just by the the test by itself as it
came out there were subtle elevations
but they were elevations that
if the validity scales hadn't been as
elevated as they were you might have
said this person has some traits
but this isn't necessarily at the level
of a true pathology however
misheard elevated a scale
that essentially is a defensiveness
scale on this test
and when you're giving this test you
always are mindful of different norms or
groups who may have similar profiles and
there are certain groups of litigants
who tend to elevate this scale as well
so i had that in mind however
ms heard elevated this so much
that it was far beyond
the
mean
for the the litigants that are known to
have the highest levels of this scale
this defensiveness scale and when this
scale is elevated to the level that it
is you automatically understand that it
is very likely that those clinical
scales we i keep doing this because i'm
seeing it in my head it looks like sort
of
an ect it's sort of these peaks you see
on a graph and when you see these peaks
and you have this huge peak over here
for the defensiveness scale what you
know is that these peaks are
artificially they've been lowered or
suppressed based on the respondent being
so defensive they still detected what's
likely there for her
but it's not as high as it should be so
you make an adjustment
and the recommendation is that anything
at 60 or above we call it a t-score of
60 or above is considered significant
miss herds were already over 60 some
were quite higher than that and then you
see a very clear profile and that was
how i got that i had mentioned a three
six code type now the test does its own
correction also for some of the scores
but not the ones that are her main code
type
with the test correction she had a 136
code type which is very similar
what is a 3 6 code type
a 3 6 code type is something that has
been researched and found to be highly
correlated or probabilistic of certain
behavioral tendencies and personality
traits and the traits with the three six
code type tend to be marked by
a lot of externalization of blame
a lot of denial about one's own personal
faults
intentional or not intentional but just
extreme denial
hostility that is
strongly controlled and suppressed the
person may not even realize how hostile
there are they are but family members
those closest to them are very likely to
report that they lose their temper and
when they lose their temper it explodes
we have sort of what we call a cookbook
for these code types which and it will
provide you with all the information
that's been researched to be associated
with them and our cookbook actually
states that that 3-6 profile
specifically tends to be associated with
cruel and ruthless behavior particularly
to those who they perceive as less
powerful than them and subordinates
describe for the jury the review process
that you did that you went through
relative to the mmpi
so uh
i
conducted a very methodical analysis of
the scores i do this for every test and
i also did it when i was reviewing dr
hughes's scores
so
what you haven't seen that's in
discovery is that i created a 25-page
outline just of her scores
with uh and it's sort of a table so i'll
put the score i'll do it in sections so
that i can understand different
groupings different research studies and
i start with looking at all the validity
scales so i put in the score i put and
i'll even color the table to show me if
it's kind of in the high zone moderate
zone or low and then if it's low is it a
significant low score or is it just low
so it doesn't mean anything and then i
in the right side i put all the research
data that i found on
this particular scale score and so i
start with the validity scales the way
the person approached the test
then i go down to essentially
we call these the first factor so their
overall
sense of well-being and how well they
cope on this actually ms herds
she endorsed scores or
endorsed items that were the opposite of
ptsd so
really saying that she feels
free of distress
and that she views herself very well
so then i go down to control
self-control loss of control coping
abilities and i put in the scores that
are associated with that in the research
and the test development
then i go down to clinical and
personality pathology and i look at all
the scores that are significant there
first with the top level main scores
then with all of the different sub
scores again citing the research the
meaning the level of elevation and what
that means and then i do comparison with
different research groups so for ms
heard i did a section that looked at
all sorts of different scores that have
been implicated with a ptsd presentation
to see if any of those were consistent
i can't remember how many there were i
think i put 13 on there but i could be
wrong uh but i believe that there was
only one that could even be in some
research is sometimes associated with it
but it was general anxiety which turned
out to be more trait specific i looked
at the scores that are typical of women
with ipv first were not consistent at
all with those i looked at the scores
that were consistent with people who are
frequently in litigation hers actually
were
very highly correlated with those that
tends to be
also consistent with a 3-6 code type and
the reason for that is believed to be
that they tend to perceive themselves
often as victims who need to avenge
wrongs
were there
other results
you believe dr hughes to have
misrepresented
whatever the tsi too
yes um so
dr hughes
generally said that testing supported
ptsd and that there was an etiology for
her trauma of intimate partner violence
she did reference that uh essentially
the
i can't remember if she said that the
trauma symptom inventory
indicated ptsd but she did say that the
elevation on that validity scale is
consistent with ptsd and that's simply
not true
that scale was designed and has been
tested and shown to be there to show
when somebody is endorsing extremely
unusual items that are not consistent
with ptsd and even though when some
people are experiencing ptsd their
distress level is so high that they'll
engage in what we call a cry for help
and they may sometimes exaggerate
distress again when you're looking at
scores as high as miss herds
and then you're not seeing indications
of ptsd and the more
subtle tests where she doesn't know what
she's endorsing
there's
it's good evidence that her
over-endorsement on that one test
is because of the reason the scale was
made to detect exaggeration and feigning
of symptoms
is this the test that
resulted in the 98 percentile
yes on that squat on that atypical
response scale and what does that 98
percentile score represent
so that 98th percentile score just
represents that
among 98 98 of people who take that test
would not have endorsed
[Music]
she scored more of those unusual items
that are not consistent with ptsd than
98 of people who have ever taken that
test
does that relate to this concept you
talked about before called feigning
yes what is feigning again
well feigning is essentially
exaggerating
symptoms of a disorder
um
i think the third
thing you indicated you were going to
talk about was
self-reports and personal opinion as
facts
what are you talking about
so
in any science and in psychology
specifically
it's really important that we use
precise language and we say what we mean
and we do not present opinions as facts
because when you are
in the role of an expert witness
or an expert in any setting essentially
a layperson may not be able to detect
the difference between something that is
a personal opinion that you're giving
versus something that is substantiated
by research data test data reliable test
methods
uh our ethics talk about especially the
specialty guidelines of forensic
psychology
the responsibility we have to
distinguish between
data
then inferences we're making from that
data what the data can mean sort of like
those tables i do i put the data the
inferences based on the research and
then what my ultimate opinion is
integrating all of that data and it's
very important that
we clarify that to the fact finder to
the judge the jury that's our
responsibility that we do not cloak
personal opinions or the self-report of
an examinee
as an expert factor somehow
scientifically based when it is just a
personal opinion or self-report of an
examinee what do you mean by self-report
the self-report is essentially what the
examinee tells you during the interview
okay
um
when did dr hughes do this
most
she did this most when describing
instances of alleged ipv
and there's also an issue there because
one of our ethics also discusses the
importance of relevance and withholding
essentially constraining our testimony
to the data and not including private
information personal information that
unnecessarily compromises the dignity of
any of the litigants
she
provided a lot of uh what
was ms heard's report to her the
allegations of abuse when describing mr
depp who she had not examined when
describing mr depp's behavior his
motivations i believe she used the word
obsessive jealousy quite a few times
talked about misheard being in a highly
dangerous situation these are simply
things that we cannot detect based on
testing and a psychological evaluation
we have to evaluate the person we have
to get consent
and we can only describe an individual
not whether or not ipv has occurred and
we certainly shouldn't go into explicit
details about sexual encounters or other
things that are highly prejudicial
shocking and hard to forget
all right um dr hughes says that miss
hurt has ptsd do you agree i do not why
not the role results of my multi-method
comprehensive evaluation based on
carefully selected researched relevant
test meth test instruments
based on comparing those instruments to
misheard self-report observing ms
heard's behavior over 12 direct hours of
assessment
reviewing copious notes from prior
therapists who indicated symptoms in
their notes reviewing the notes of nurse
philadelphi previously nurse forum who
spent
i believe at one point almost two months
with misheard daily um reviewing the
notes of her treating providers
uh
let's see
all of the legal documents and discovery
there was no evidence of ptsd
how is evidence ptsd
generally
exhibited
so
really the bottom line in a forensic
psychological evaluation
is
a change in functioning that's what
we're looking for again i said we don't
have a crystal ball we're not wizards we
can't get into somebody's head
what we're looking for were their
identifiable changes
in the way the person engaged in their
world were they able to keep a job ptsd
is an extremely disabling diagnosis
when a person has true ptsd it is
difficult for them to work you'll see
unemployment job loss
it causes extreme levels of distress and
impairment there's divorce there's
isolation and estrangement from children
from family members
extreme alcohol abuse often a string of
sudden duis when the person never had
any before they become homebound they
can't go to the store
they're certainly not going to events
they're not uh having success in their
film career usually they're not
exercising every day pursuing their
hobbies being avid readers obtaining
level three sommelier training having
dinner parties with friends speaking to
public groups
those are just
indications of very high functioning and
when you're looking for a decrease in
functioning over time that is
inconsistent with that decrease
what about dr hughes's suggestion that
mr waldman's statements
served as a trigger
for miss herd's ptsd
all right
dr hughson suggested that
perhaps
ms hurt's ptsd was somehow triggered
what's your view on that
i would say that it can't be triggered
if ptsd isn't present
thank you very much doctor
all right cross examination
dr curry i just want to make sure that
uh we all remember you're not board
certified correct no i'm not okay and
you've been licensed for how long i've
been licensed for 10 years okay and you
are being paid by mr depp's legal team
to be here correct yes how much have you
charged so far
i actually don't know
over a hundred thousand
i truly don't know i don't do my own
books over two hundred thousand
i don't know
over three hundred thousand that would
be way too much but i do not know
okay
um now just so that we all remember
you had dinner
at mr depp's house
for three to four hours
with mr depp mr waltman mr chu and ms
vasquez correct
i was interviewed i asked if there was
anything i could eat because at about
three hours i started to get hungry
mr depp then offered to order take out
for the entire team
so you had dinner with me at mr depp's
home
with mr waldman
mr chu ms vasquez and mr deck correct
yes and you had drinks as well correct i
actually don't know i do remember that
there were drinks do you recall
testifying earlier that you did have a
drink of mule something
no i remember testifying that there
might have been a mule
a moscow mule okay thank you we didn't
have animals there as well right no
animals okay that's good to know and and
you talked about transparency i just
want to make sure
you
had several
designations expert designations and
reports in this case correct yes and
then not one of them
did you disclose that you had dinner and
drinks at mr depp's house for three to
four hours with mr waldman mr chu and ms
vasquez is that correct ms bredehoff
you're mischaracterizing what occurred
dr curry please answer the question not
once did you disclose this in any of
your room i did not disclose that i was
interviewed as that standard procedure
but it's true that you have never gone
to a client's house to be interviewed
for an expert witness position correct
yes because i never had a client that
was essentially homebound because of
their celebrity status all right and and
you
talked to mr depp for three to four
hours
uh before taking on the role
of assessing ms heard in deciding
whether she was suffering from any
distress correct i did not talk to mr
depp i was talking to his legal team and
he was there to observe
he was present for the three to four
hours and are you saying now he just
stayed silent and said nothing all day i
don't recall what he didn't or didn't do
i was answering questions okay now your
expertise here
is limited to whether amber heard
suffers from ptsd currently is that
correct
yes i was tasked with conducting an
evaluation to determine this herd's
mental status very very strict time
limitations okay because we've promised
to get this case to the jury so i really
appreciate if you just answer my
question rather than trying to go for
sure okay thank you very much now
after you did had the dinner
you then provided the designation in
february of 2021
in which you said and this is long
before you ever saw amber heard correct
you said that amber heard quote exhibits
patterns of behavior that are consistent
with co-occurring cluster b personality
disorder traits especially borderline
personality disorder end of quote
correct no
no you
we went through this before we did but
and that was on the designation was it
not
i i told you last time that i did not
write that okay and you don't know who
did on the legal team correct no okay
and then i also asked you if you may
recall whether you listened to the audio
recording in which mr depp taunted amber
heard that she had a borderline
personality disorder do you recall that
i recall you asking me that yes did you
recall listening to that audio tape
i don't recall mr depp taunting misheard
i do recall
that he at some point suggested she
might have that diagnosis okay and that
was back in these audio tapes back when
they were together correct
yes okay now you've never before been
asked to testify or serve as an expert
with respect to someone who has bipolar
disorder correct
no as i previously stated that's not
true
all right
[Music]
all right
yes
now you recall testifying in your
deposition on march 21 2022 correct yes
and you were under
oath at that time correct yes and the
question i just showed you on page 207
line
five
have you ever been asked to testify or
serve as an expert with respect to
whether someone has bipolar disorder and
your answer at that time was no correct
yes i had forgotten that case okay and
have you ever been asked to testify
whether anyone has
behavioral or characterological conduct
that suggests they may be an ipv
perpetrator
i can't yeah i may have it's difficult
after about 250 cases it's difficult to
remember specifically all right and have
you ever been qualified as an expert in
the area of ipv
no
and have you ever been qualified to
testify as an expert in domestic abuse
or violence
violent oh domestic
abuse or violence
yes that's been a component of testimony
can i take a look
okay
line 16 of page 207 have you ever been
qualified as an expert in the area of
ipv your answer on line 20 was no under
oath correct then the next question have
you ever been qualified to testify as an
expert in domestic abuse or violence
that and goes into page 208 line four
the answer then under oath was no
now
you would agree
that the literature is quite clear that
trauma-based
symptoms such as ptsd or complex ptsd
have symptoms that overlap with
borderline personality disorder and
histrionic personality disorder yes yes
okay and you would agree that it's
important to use valid and reliable
measures for an accurate diagnosis
correct absolutely okay
you chose however not to administer
the structured clinical interview for
dsm-5 personality disorders the skin is
that correct i did okay and would you
agree that that is a state-of-the-art
structured clinical interview
not for a forensic evaluation with a
sophisticated examinee but to determine
if a personality disorder is present no
not in this setting you don't agree with
that i do not you don't agree that that
is the gold standard assessment for
reliable accurate psychiatric diagnosis
it's a good one but for treatment
settings especially okay
now did ms heard you said you talked
about you read all of the treatment
records right
yes okay do you recall reading the
treatment records for the psychologist
bonnie jacobs who saw amber heard over
five years i do and did you see anything
in bonnie jacobs notes over five years
in which she diagnosed ms heard with
borderline personality or histrionic
personality disorder no
now you also saw the notes of dr
connor
connell cohen correct
and you even attended his deposition
correct yes all right and he saw amber
for roughly two years he was part of the
dr kipper connection right
yes okay and did you see anything in dr
collins notes
and did he say in his deposition that he
diagnosed amber heard with borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder i saw the symptoms
clearly delineated throughout his notes
and in his deposition he does not use
diagnoses so he would not have diagnosed
her he said specifically in his
deposition he did not diagnose her with
that correct yes and he also
specifically stated that he does not use
diagnoses all right and you also have
seen dr banks dr amy banks the
psychiatrist for her deposition correct
yes and diagnostic deposition i reviewed
her notes in the transcript all right
did dr anderson diagnose ms heard with
borderline personality disorder or
histrionic personality disorder i don't
believe she provided any diagnosis since
she was a couple's therapist all right
now you've said quite a bit about don
hughes but do you remember how many
years of experience don hughes has in
ipv and domestic abuse and violence i
know it's quite a bit extensive and she
is board certified correct yes she is
all right and she spent 29 hours of
examination with amber heard she did she
not
yes mostly interviewing all right and
she admitted and she interviewed her
therapists bonnie jacobs and conan collo
correct yes and she also interviewed
amber's late mother
yes okay and she administered 12
different tests
over the period of that time correct
well as i said the majority of those
were checklists which are inappropriate
for the forensic setting i i understand
that's what you say but she administered
12 different tests correct
if you want to qualify them as tests
sure okay
and so
you did you disregard whatever nah i'm
not even going to say that okay
let's go to the caps 5 and ptsd now you
assessed ms heard's traumas in her life
correct
uh
yes i did i gave her an instrument to
assess for any trauma exposure
throughout the entire lifespan yes yes
it's fine and you wrote that miss hurd's
exposure to a traumatic event namely one
of the sexual assaults by mr depp
more than satisfied this requirement did
you not write that in your notes
that is not what i wrote in my notes do
you have my notes and you administered a
structured clinical interview based on
that trauma correct
not exactly it's not quite right okay
now dr hughes administered a full
intimate partner violence assessment
correct
that's not a psychological assessment we
can't assess for intimate partner
violence that's an event dr hughes
administered a full intimate partner
violence assessment she stated that and
that's actually something i'm rebutting
today okay and you reviewed her
psychological testing i sure did yes
okay and are you aware that in september
2019
ms heard had a trauma-based symptom on
many of those valid tests
um can you be a little bit more specific
many of those valid tests which tests
are you talking about do you have a
recollection of that september 2019
she administered all of her testing in
september 2019 so i'm not sure
which one oh except for the caps 5 which
was 10 days after mine in 2021
now dr hughes clinically evaluated those
symptoms and established that ms heard
does have ptsd from the totality of the
intimate partner violence by mr depp
correct
that's what she stated yesterday
now
dr anderson's clinical notes that said
amber had come to objection hearsay
i have i haven't even asked the question
yet your honor
are you going to read her notes well let
me no no actually i i wasn't going to
read her no i'm just going to ask a
particular question you talked about
danger do you recall that in your
testimony yes all right now if
if a patient comes to you as a couple's
therapist
with two black eyes
would you assess there that there may be
a potential danger there
sure okay did you read dr anderson's
notes
i believe i did
now you administered the minnesota
multiphasic personality inventory two
the mmpi two do you recall that yes and
you used that to determine whether amber
had ptsd right it
not by itself but it was a part of the
data okay
and in the 60 to 70 t-score range for
that test
which quote deliberate attempts to
mislead our uncommon common end quote
isn't that correct sorry could you
repeat that
in the t-score
section of that
for which assesses deliberate attempts
to mislead
do you recall she scored a 60 on that
test correct so there are multiple
t-scores for at each scale so i'm not
sure which
scale you're talking about okay
well we can deal with that later so you
would agree that you need to follow
ethics and best practices in forensic
psychology correct yes okay and the two
primary sources are the american
psychological association ethical
principles and professional code of
conduct right
and the american psychological
association's specialty guidelines for
forensic psychology correct yes and
specialty guidelines 1.02
states that forensic practitioners quote
strive for accuracy impartiality
fairness and independence correct yes
okay and specialty guidelines 1.03
states that you have to avoid a conflict
of interest correct
now
in addition
to not listing the four hours you've
spent with mr depp mr waldman mr chu and
ms vasquez
you also did not list that you spent an
hour with dr shaw correct
that's incorrect
you say that you that the designation
said that you during my deposition i
also clarified this i didn't spend an
hour with dr shaw there was an
introduction with the attorneys present
on zoom
my time on that call was less than 30
minutes okay but you still didn't
disclose it did you in your reports no
okay
now
you are not you have not been asked to
testify about ms herd's behavior in the
context of her relationship with mr depp
is that correct
i was asked to testify about somebody's
behavioral mental status in general so
that can include
behavior involved in a relationship with
mr deb but not specifically
can you pull up day 10
of
the trial testimony at page 2710
2710 line lines 12 through 18.
may will you approach
all
all
right
um
oh
thank you great job
okay does the witness also have okay yep
so dr curry this is your testimony from
day 10 in this case and if you can look
at page 2710
um line 13 now is it your my question
was now is it your testimony under oath
today that you have not been asked to
testify concerning miss herd's behavior
in the context of her relationship with
mr depp including any abuse
and your answer under oath to this jury
that day was that's correct yes correct
i still agree with that to that question
all right and you have not made any
determinations including any opinions
that ms heard abused mr depp or mr deb
abuse misheard correct
correct
okay and and in fact you said that's
outside the scope yes okay of psychology
and you cannot testify whether amber
heard suffered any emotional distress as
a result of any of the defamatory
comments that she has alleged mr waldman
made through mr deb or mr depp made
through mr waldman correct objection
your honor
do you want me to read my response your
objection
hold on to doctor
that's okay what's the objection are you
on approach okay
now
you have not rendered any open opinion
as to whether amber heard
exhibits patterns of behavior that would
suggest her allegations of abuse against
mr deb are false would you agree
no
i mean yes i would agree with that thank
you and you have not
no that's right that's all i've got no
further questions all right redirect
you were asked about the
skid
yes what's that
it's a structured clinical interview
uh it's for rendering a diagnosis it's
best for treatment because you're asking
direct questions of the examinee and
about symptoms so if you have an
examinee who has a tendency to minimize
you're not going to get much information
why didn't you use it
because uh well first of all i had a
limited amount of time for my evaluation
and i already had to
use
just to complete the interview was
extremely time consuming
and i had to even restructure it into
handouts so that i could
keep misheard on track i
determined based on that so this is
where you would make an inference so
because i was having difficulty
getting
direct answers to my questions from ms
heard
i had determined that creating forms of
those questions would be a better use of
the time which it was and then i further
deduced that adding on the structured
clinical interview would probably be
unproductive given that i had limited
time and needed to use the best most
reliable methods for getting information
in that time
you were asked about the apa specialty
guidelines yes specifically 1.02
1.03 have you complied with them i have
no further questions thank you
thank you dr crew you can have a seat in
the courtroom you're ready to go thank
you man
all right ladies let's go ahead and take
our morning recess for 15 minutes do not
discuss the case and do not do the
outside research okay
so
all right
just for planning purposes
sammy asked mr tobin to be here as early
as noon just in case with the fluid of
the trial i'm not sure what time we get
to that motion so
okay just let you know
they need to work on that they're going
to find out who the next witness is um
so let's go ahead and take a re-recess
until 10 55 okay
all right thank you
all right are we ready for the jury uh
no your honor we do have a issue we'd
like to sure
all right your next witness
i'm sorry let's get the jury first right
all right you ready for the jury
so
now
all right thank you
are you
ready for the next witness or do you
want to call uh mr duck okay
all right
so just a reminder you're still under
oath okay
all right thank you sir
good morning mr duff good morning
um we heard
a lot about some statements that mr
waldman made do you remember that
yes
and mr waldman
is your attorney or was your attorney
yes
could we please pull up defendants
exhibit 1245
and this is already an evidence so
permission to please yes publish
if we could scroll down to the second
page
mr depp do you see the statement here
attributed to mr waldman
yes i do
when's the first time that you saw this
statement
um
all right
thank you
mr deb when is the first time that you
saw this statement by mr waldman
um
the first time that i
ever saw this statement
was in august
um it was when the piece was the the the
um
when she
august 2020 when i was countersued by
misheard
is the first time that i saw any of
these uh
statements
can we please pull up defendant's
defendants exhibit 1246
and this is also already in evidence
thank you we could scroll down to the
second page
or the
third perhaps thank you
mr depp do you see this statement that's
attributed to mr waldman here
i do
and
when is the first time that you saw
these statements
it's the same uh when the only counter
suit was filed
and could we please go to defense
exhibit 1247.
and again this is already in evidence
if we could scroll down please thank you
mr deb do you see the
statement attributed to mr waldman i do
indeed yes and when's the first time
that you saw this statement
the the the this is the same it's
the
counter claim to august 2020
after you saw these statements for the
first time did you form an understanding
as to where they appeared
i didn't uh as to where they had
appeared these statements
in what publication
um
no off the bat i didn't
know exactly
um
[Music]
it just seemed like a lot of word
salad to me
i didn't know where they'd come from or
i mean
where they ended up
mr depp do you recall miss herd
testifying that she you did not assist
her in getting her role in aquaman
uh yes i do yes
and what is your response to that
um
um
it's not it's not um it's not exactly
true do you know when miss heard first
auditioned for aquaman
strangely i know the day you know well
yes i do know the day
because
um
i was scheduled
uh with um
my band the uh the the hollywood
vampires uh we had done two shows at the
roxy which is a place in los angeles to
um rehearse for a uh
we were invited to play at the rock and
reel
concert which is a huge rock and roll
festival
so we did the two shows to go to rio
and play there
mr
uh i wanted you wanted to
come with me and
whitney your sister had come as well
um while we were there in
rio and we were rehearsing
getting ready for the show
uh
mr informed me that she would have to be
going she would have to get back to
los angeles for an audition
meaning um
this is basically after our
two-hour show or whatever
we had to
we would have to get on the plane
immediately to make it back to los
angeles
um for this audition
and um that audition was uh
at warner brothers it was
whatever film it was and when were you
performing at the rock in rio oh sorry
yeah that was the
i believe it was the 24th of september
in what year ah that was
15.
what do you understand happened after
miss heard auditioned for aquaman
um
after after
ms heard's uh
audition or possibly auditions
uh for warner brothers and uh
i suppose the creative team
um
mr
expressed to me that
the
film was going to be warner brothers had
said the film is going to be shooting in
australia
and
australia was a
for miss her that was a potential
problem
which objection your honor
your approach okay
i apologize mr duck could you please
continue what happened after miss heard
auditioned for aquaman
uh shh
i was informed
by ms heard that the film was going to
be
shooting in australia
and
that that was of um
concern to her
and because there it was of concern
to warner brothers
so she asked if i would
because i i'd had a i'd had a
um
for a few years i've had a multi-film
uh deal with with warner brothers and uh
so we've been in business together so
i knew
these people i've been in
i've been on films with them
so i
she asked me if i would speak to them
i made a phone call and i i spoke to uh
objection hearsay your honor
i don't believe he said anything i think
he was going to say who he spoke to all
right let's see overruled at this point
um
i spoke to
three um the three upper echelon
disney executive excuse me warner
executives kevin tsujihara sue kroll
and
greg silverstein
and
i told them objection your honor hearsay
all right i'll see any objection next
question
um what was the result of you speaking
with those individuals
um
well i i i i i um
i can only say that ultimately she did
she did get the
job in the film
so hopefully i i i suppose i had curbed
their
worries to some degree
mr depp do you recall miss heard
testifying that she saw you consume
eight to ten mdma pills while you were
at once while you were in australia in
um march of 2015.
yes i do remember that
i also remember saying that i took a
handful objection beyond the scope
question sorry i just that was extra
resonating i'll sustain the objection
next question
how many times have you done mdma in
your life mr depp
uh actually not many not that many times
i would say in my lifetime maybe
in my lifetime mdma
six seven
maybe
and how much mdma have you done on those
occasions
oh not enough to um
not enough to
uh
properly
well not not enough to properly properly
experience the
what the um
chemicals are supposed to
do to you
have you ever consumed eight to ten mdma
pills at once
no no no i have not and why is that um
because i'd be dead i'm pretty sure i'd
be dead
i think one would die yes
and
probably rather quickly
mr duff i'd like to show you some
pictures from the home in australia that
ms heard testified about true could we
please pull up defendants exhibit 1817
which is already in evidence
mr deb do you recognize what's depicted
in this photograph
uh yes i do that's the um that's the
downstairs bar um
of the
house we rented in australia
can you please show the jury where you
were sitting when misheard threw
um the two vodka bottles at you
um
if i touch this thing we'll make a yes
as well okay
so
this chair
that one
here was
over here
and and it was in pretty much when i was
turned around toward the wrong swivel so
when i was turned around towards the bar
i'm facing the bar when i turned around
this way the chair
this chair
here was
in
uh pretty much exactly this same
position as this chair
it was fatal when i was facing
um
miss her
who was
let's issues
if you're looking at the photograph she
would be about here
could you uh draw a line in the
direction where misheard was relative to
where you were sitting yes absolutely so
if i'm sitting here
um
she was over here
like back here
approximately how far away from his herd
from you was miss hurt if you can recall
i would say i i would say it was
probably
10 12 15 feet maybe go
10 feet 12 feet
and
approximately where was your hand when
the vodka bottle hit it
it was um
it was leaning
my arm wasn't sorry my my arm was
leaning on the um
the marble bar
um
right there where that the imaginary
seat is
uh
leaning
and kind of just leaning back and and um
looking at misheard she just walked away
with the
second bottle
uh well i mean she walked this way when
she threw the first bottle which is
uh
actually visible
can you cross her over the floor
yeah
could you please circle where the first
bottle oh sorry excuse me
all that is the um
exploded first bottle
that
went past my
it went past my head
and the second bottle
um
hit
right up here where my hand was resting
on the um
marble bar
can we please pull up defendants exhibit
1820.
mr deb do you recognize what's depicted
in this photograph
this is behind that very bar
and what do you see on the floor in this
picture
um i see what looks to me like a
uh some kind of napkin it looks
solid soiled
blood i don't know and i see
glass
in the
corner blood obviously on the
floor
and um a towel
leaning up on some something
do you know how that bloody tissue got
on the floor
um
i
my best guess um
objection calls for speculation
do you know how the blood got on the
floor mr dab i'm pretty well i know how
the blood got on the floor it came
from my dripping finger
so that's why the tissue
um
is is uh
i'm
99.9
sure since it is
looks like he's got blood on it as well
is what what i um
held my finger
held my finger
with
do you see the wall to the on the left
side of the photograph
i do
was there a wall mounted phone on that
wall
on the left side of the photo
no i didn't no uh
no
not that i recall no
uh could we please pull up defendants
exhibit 394 which is already in evidence
yes
mr depp do you recognize this text
message
i
i do
and what what is this message
um
it's a
it's a text to dr
kippur
i'm sorry just reading through
yeah this is
this is
my text to the to to
dr kipper who who had just happened to
be in town
um
telling him that uh
i've had it and um that
i just lost a finger that fingertip
how long after your finger had been
injured did you send this text message
if you can recall
it's hard it's hard to tell because i'm
going to look at the time stamp it's
it's delivered 3 7 2015 5
o'clock
um
but i know that because of australia
time
it was the eighth
and it was probably this was
the whole thing lasted probably until
about two pm
um or so when when that was when
kipper was called jerry was brought in
and
jerry judge sorry excuse me
so do you have an estimate as to how
long after your finger had actually been
injured that you sent this message
i i don't think it was very long i think
it was probably
within the next
it was in i'm sure it was in the next
half hour or
so
um i would have had to sneak into a
bathroom lock myself in to
type this out
and how were you able to send this text
message to dr kipper in the state that
you were in
um
well
he wasn't available at the time so um
just to
sort of thumb your way through don't you
how long after sending this text message
did you see dr kipper
um i i don't recall that i think it it
took them probably
for 30 minutes or
more
30 to 40 minutes to get there and what
did dr kipper
do when he first arrived at the home
oh the first thing he wanted to do is
inspect
the damage of my finger
and try and
figure out exactly what had happened
how it happened
and what did you tell dr kipper about
how your finger had been injured
objection your honor
you'll be
several times
mr depp when dr kipper was treating your
finger what did you tell him about how
your finger became injured
um
i told him
i told him that there was obviously i
mean
when you saw the
damage in the house and everything the
blood everywhere i mean obviously there
was serious damage
done um i
there would be no point in
lying to the man he'd been through a bit
with me and
and um
before i told him that she had
thrown about a
bottle of vodka and smashed my hair
smashed
and cut my finger
off
the tip of my finger just
put a good chunk
i miss it
uh mr deb you heard ms hurd testify
about an alleged incident of abuse on
your honeymoon do you remember that
i remember a testifying guy yes and
when did you and miss heard go on your
honeymoon together
i believe
it was somewhere in the neighborhood of
august
um because i just finished the film
maybe end of july
um august
i'm not quite
good on the exact date do you recall the
year
it was
2015 i believe
and where did you and miss herd go on
your honeymoon
um we we um took the
uh
the orient express
um
from
bangkok
thailand to singapore
and what happened while you and miss
heard were together on the orient
express
um
there were there were times when it was
very
agreeable very nice
and then there were
times when
um
something some
something had become dissatisfactory for
her and
she would
start the
the
rant
the blooming of the
of a fight
would would be on deck there and uh
and and
one
at one point
didn't i mean i don't remember lasting
long at all i i just remember that um
i i took a pretty good uh
shot to the
um
to the face to the eye to somewhere up
here
so i had a bit of a
shiner
but it but but the
it all went
ended and then everything got fine again
and we'd go to dinner and it was all
fine
did miss hurt ever apologize to you for
giving you the shiner
i don't i don't recall
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 162
which is already in evidence
mr depp do you recognize this
photograph i do it was with the the yes
the the um the chef and the
major dean the staff were asking if they
could take a photo with us and they've
been very kind at giving us a
private dinner so where was this
photograph taken that was in the um
um
that looks like it's in the yes that's
towards the back of the orient express
that's in the
the
the back train bar compartment
and just out back you could smoke on the
on the
sort of caboose order
and
what if any injuries do you have in this
photograph
i think the um
the eye's a little bit
bugged out
if you will
it's yeah
how did that happen
um
these things could happen very quickly
if
if
if you disagreed
objection your honor non-responsive she
just asked how did that happen
i believe he was about to explain well
stay in the objection okay so
mr duff specifically how did the injury
in this photograph occur oh i'm sure it
hit me
up better
um does this picture accurately reflect
what you looked like on that date
i don't look at myself much but it
certainly looks like me with a black eye
does this picture appear to have been
photographed uh photoshopped in any way
no i think no i think would be difficult
to photograph or to
start getting into sort of digital
processing with a number of people in
the shop especially in a wide shot
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 1301 and this is a new one your
honor so this is not in evidence
mr depp do you recognize what's
reflected in this photograph
yes this is the
the staff uh it's the manager
and
his staff at the um
raffles hotel in singapore
and
before we left they uh they asked if
they could take a photograph with us
and when was this photograph taken
um
well that would have been we were off
the orient express we stayed in raffles
i believe a couple of
a couple of days few days
and then from there we flew to san
francisco
so this photograph was taken after the
photograph we just looked at
that this photograph was taken after the
photograph in the dining car of the
train yes
uh your honor i moved uh plaintiff's
exhibit 1301 into evidence
oh happy honeymoon
31st of october any objection
no objection you're honest all right
1301 isn't evidence can be published to
the jury
mr depp what if any injuries do you see
on your face in this photograph
i see pretty much the same i i
i see that
the the area in here has been um well is
uh
swollen and uh
um yeah there's a bit of a shiner there
thank you we can take this down
mr depp do you recall miss herd
testifying that she
punched you um in the staircase incident
because she thought of miss kate moss in
the stairs
do i remember saying that yes
yes i do three times
yes i do
do you have any understanding as to what
ms heard was referring to
i yes i do
but
um as as k
moss um kate testified
it was many many years ago
um
and what exactly what happened is
what she said happened
i
uh
recall i recall
um
speaking with ms heard about and uh
that in that very incident
um
because of
the down
downpouring of rain because it was
raining very heavily that day that kate
slipped
and i recalled the story to her
objection your honor hearsay
uh may we approach it
please continue mr deck what did you
tell miss heard about the staircase or
kate moss
i'll make it easy for mr
rotten
born
mr
took the story
and
turned it into
[Music]
a very ugly incident
all in her
mind
there was never
a moment
where i pushed kate down any set of
stairs
yet she's spewed this three times before
objection your honor miss heard simply
testified that she'd heard a rumor and
that's what responds to the question sir
hold on objection
overrule the objection
sorry i was drawn by mr roddenborns
voice
certainly what would you like
um
so what what specifically had you
actually told miss heard about
the incident with miss moss and the
stairs
very simply that she had
we were in jamaica
um
i had left our bungalow
about three minutes prior to her i was
standing outside and suddenly rain
starts just coming down like it's you
know
a monsoon and then i remember looking
and seeing kate
coming out the door and there were three
little
wooden stairs and she slipped her legs
went up
and she landed directly on her coccyx
and her lower back
so and she was obviously physically
in pain uh and
she was hurt she was crying so i ran
over and
grabbed her to make you know to make
sure she was all right
um
that's that's it that's the oh that's
all i ever
that's the whole story
but then um
the rumor
of it
i'd never heard
a rumor of that
before
miss heard
grabbed hold of it
it's like that i'm sorry
mr depp uh we heard testimony from miss
heard's sister whitney during this trial
do you remember that
yes
and how would you describe your
relationship with whitney when you were
in a relationship with miss heard
i
i liked whitney very much um initially i
mean when i first met her i liked her
very much
um and grew to love whitney
um
very much um
because i i always
it seemed
whitney amber's sister whitney seemed to
always get the
the the sort of dirty end of the stick
and um
i i felt bad
for her for that because
it wasn't new
it had been there for for life
and that was that was
seemed pretty obvious
so i i i took uh i took to whitney
um
very very quickly very easily
she was she was a very sweet kid she was
wonderful
what do you mean that
whitney got the dirty end of the stick
um
it was kind of a strange combination of
loving sister
trusted
sister and friend
and then
lackey
and
then you know either
the punching bag or the dartboard
or the recipient of
of some rather demeaning and ugly
um
words or
she would have wine thrown in her face
and who was the source of those
demeaning words and the wine that you
just referenced well the amber heard her
sister and
how do you know that
well i witnessed quite a lot of it
the wine in the
face
was something that happened in new york
which
i think that even made it into the
papers
i believe that even made it into the
papers it was in an elevator
how did you first learn about that
incident i'm sorry told me
in detail
what else did you observe of
um miss heard and her sister whitney's
interactions during your relationship
with miss heard
they were just constantly up and down
but i you know
i could
i could sense i could feel that
whitney
was
trying to please her sister trying to
be up to snuff
and um
it just seemed like she got shot down in
your honor it's gone beyond the scope of
the question or
his foundation for knowledge of that
your honor i i asked
what he observed you know between them i
think this is responsive to that
and his testimonies of what whitney felt
is
i'll sustain the objection next question
did you ever see miss heard physically
attack whitney
no i've never seen any
full-on blowouts
physical blowouts between them
tons of
verbal uh
blow action beyond the scope
overruled
um
i
i've certainly seen miss her grab
whitney
push her push her around
uh
there were a number
number
there were half a dozen times when
uh we
some of us whoever whoever was in the
general vicinity would have to leave
um
this is at orange when
whitney and amber were living in orange
whitney and her boyfriend
at the time sean krazewski
and uh he
we actually we had to leave the
apartment
and wait in the car
while they
fought and when you say fought do you
mean physically or physical
and when you said misheard would push
whitney around do you mean that
physically push her metaphorically
both
you heard whitney testify that she
lived in penthouse 4 at the eastern
columbia building for a time
correct that is correct yes
um
how did whitney come to live in
penthouse 4
my recollection when whitney first came
to
stay at the um eastern columbia building
in penthouse 4 was
she and her
boyfriend sean had
broken up
and
she needed a place to go
and so amber asked if she could stay in
penthouse 4 and i
i've said
of course she of course you know
how long did whitney live in penthouse 4
um
it was well over a year on and off
did you ever ask whitney to move out of
penthouse
4. no i did not know
why did whitney ultimately move out of
penthouse 4
objection foundation
it's his apartment your honor he was
living there
[Music]
whitney moved out of
penthouse for
long before the
um marriage
and it was due to a
an argument that ms hurd and whitney had
had
which had to do with um
whitney working at the art of elysium
with jennifer howell and those people
and stand
our asked her to leave get out
where did whitney live when she moved
out of penthouse for
my understanding she went to live with
jennifer howell
uh your honor i know you um anticipated
having a motion at noon
you can keep going that's okay we can
how much longer and direct do you have
um i have a bed okay it's okay
uh mr dub do you recall hearing
testimony during ms heard's case
um from mr mandel
yes i do and and who is that
mr mandel is uh my former business
manager of 17 and a half years
who
at a
certain point i um
uh
discovered
had been
embezzling quite a lot of money
so i had to
take action against
him and he and and and my lawyer of 17
and a half years as they were
in
cahoots as it were
and um
so so yes joel mandel is uh
and david which was they
they settled
um
their case
with me they made their settlement um
but yes it was it was the big that was a
very yeah joel mandel is a
a very bitter man who um ended up with a
lot of
money that i've worked hard for over the
years
do you recall mr mandel testifying in
this case that um you do not spend very
much money on charity that i don't sorry
that you do not spend very much money on
charity
objection your honor
uh mr depp just to remind you my my
question was what is your response to mr
mandel's testimony that you do not spend
very much on charity
um
my response to that is
mr mandel
is a very bitter man and um
one thing about that
me
myself personally
with regard to
charity donations
sending
money
to a charity
i
prefer
i don't i would rather that my name were
not on it i don't want the name to be
the
important thing or the thing that people
talk about
so when
i donate i
check money
i donate without my name being involved
because i
because i don't see that that's
important my name
being there
in terms of money now
if if i if i am able to
visit
hospitals or if i'm able to
um
meet with make-a-wish children
um
i have held on to the relationships that
i've held on to with in the make within
the make-a-wish foundation and the
children's hospital and
various very solid places
then my obviously my name is involved
when we held premiers in leicester
square um for
several films
of
charlie's chocolate factory again beyond
the scope of his response to mr mandel's
testimony i believe this is in response
to mr middle overrule the objection
so basically
when it be
when it was a public
let's call it donation or whatever i
would
talk to the studio i would talk to
disney i would talk to warner brothers i
would talk to whoever the studio was
well before the premiere
and
make the premiere a benefit
that would
once we did what we benefited we did a
benefit uh premiere for great ormond
street hospital
we did a benefit a couple of benefit
premieres for the make a wish foundation
um
[Music]
i mean
if you can turn a premiere
with that many thousands and thousands
and thousands of people there
into a benefit
um
it
it it works and it helps
um
but it wasn't presented under my name
you know it was disney's doing this or
warner brothers is doing this
i'm not looking for the um pat on the
back as it were if i can make it happen
great
but i don't need the pat on the back i
don't need the adulation i don't need
the attention
did you hear miss heard testify that one
of the charities she donated a portion
of your divorce settlement
to was the children's hospital of los
angeles
yes
what is your relationship with the chla
objection your honor you're relevant
to this
um mr deb what is your relationship with
the chla
um
i've had a relationship with the chla
for probably
20 years
or so
and what's the nature of that
relationship
um
well essentially since you know
sometimes there are
make-a-wish kids
who are in the hospital there and that
their wishes to
objection your honor
your honor may be approaching
mr depp i'd like to
take you back to
exactly six years prior to this week the
week of may 21st through may 27 2016.
what happened at the beginning of that
week
may
21st
uh excuse me may 20th
may 20th um
this is we're talking 2016 here yes
um
may 20th
the afternoon of may 20th
afternoon evening
my
my mom
made her
exit
she um
she'd been
fighting um
cancer
numerous times and for many years and
she
she fought
all the way
to the end
and
so my mother passed away on the 20th of
may
i
which
does bring instant perspective into
one's mind
i
spoke to amber that night i called her
on the telephone
explained to her
that my mom had passed
that is who had passed and that um
i thought that the best thing we could
do
was to um
[Music]
uh mr deb what happened at the end of
that week on may 27 2016.
may 27th my daughter's birthday
may 27th
um
i was not in los angeles i was on
the way to on tour and uh that was when
mr
went for the
restraining order
and oh yeah also that was the
that was the day that uh
um
uh alice alice threw the looking glass
um a film i'd done
was opening
did miss heard know that you were out of
town on may 27th
yes
how would she have known that
well i told her i was going on tour i
mean it was that was well established
how long were you going to be out of
town on that tour
two to three months
and did miss heard know how long you'd
be out of town
i don't know if she knew exactly how
long i'd be out of town but it was a
pretty extensive tour of europe
how did miss heard's actions on may 27th
2016 affect you
changed everything
objection your honor oh it didn't change
everything
i'm sorry if you could wait till the
objection please yes yes i'm sorry
your honor this is one of the keys
mr deb what has it been like for you to
listen to ms hurd's testimony at this
trial
i'm sorry
what has it been like for you to listen
to miss heard's testimony at this trial
objection relevance your honor
overruled
insane
it's
it's insane
to
hear
heinous
um
accusations
of
violence sexual violence
that she's attributed to me that she's
accuse me of
[Music]
um
i don't think anyone
enjoys having to
split themselves open
and tell the
truth
but um
there are times when one
just simply has to because it's gotten
out of control
it
horrible
ridiculous humiliating
ludicrous
painful
savage
un
unimaginably
brutal
cruel
and all
false
awful
um
i wanted
i i
no human being is perfect certainly not
none of us
but i
have never
in my life
committed
sexual battery
physical abuse
all these
outlandish outrageous stories
of me committing these things
and living with it for six years
and waiting to be able to
bring
the truth
out
so this is not
easy for any of us
i know that
but um
no matter what happens i did get here
and i did tell the truth
and i
have
spoken
up for
what i've been
carrying on my back
reluctantly
for six years
thank you
no further questions all right
did you want to take lunch at this point
or just okay all right let's do that all
right ladies and gentlemen let's go
ahead and take uh lunch this time do not
discuss this case with anybody and don't
do any outside research okay
thank you
and don't break anything on your way out
thank you
all right so just a reminder that since
you are back on the stand did not
discuss this case with anybody to
include your attorneys at this point
okay if you could just have a seat back
there we do have some other issues to
take care of
before we take care of
the third party motion can i have
attorneys come forward on
our
so
so
mr tobin yes sir how are you doing sir
very well thank you thank you
thank mr tommy if you could just come to
the senate room
okay
thank you thank you sir
the other side
i got to make this relatively short as
you can understand but i i wanted to
take up your motion i have read your
read your motion and the declaration and
everything attached to it in all the
cases
and i have reviewed it so i'd rather you
not regurgitate that based on our time
limit but anything you wish to add to
that is fine
if you wanted if i could focus you a
little bit okay thank you all right yes
sir uh as far as um your comments about
uh virginia rule of evidence to colon
508 that's a criminal uh rule of
evidence so i'm that's not
strong not your strongest argument uh
and as far as what goes on is when the
uh
or if the witness testifies
um
whether it's hearsay or it's
third party knowledge that's something
i'll deal with at trial so again
not what i'm concerned with as far as
supreme court rule 314
um which um i would like you to to talk
a little bit about that as far as
intervention and i got to tell you where
i'm at right now the concern the the
issue i have uh with the argument is
intervention obviously
would make you a plaintiff or defendant
in the case and it has to deal with an
issue that's germane to this case and
this is a defamation case so if you
could just tail your argument to that
issue sir sure i'm happy to address the
intervention for the record runner
charles tobin from the law firm of
ballard spar yes you're representing tmz
um which is the publisher of news and
entertainment uh for the celebrity and
entertainment industry and your honor
we're
seeking to intervene simply to protect
the relationship between reporters and
their sources
when it comes to reporting news in the
public interest we as the court noted we
we really don't have a dog in this hunt
as far as mr depp uh miss heard uh we're
really here purely on the the first
amendment based issue of reporters
privilege and reporters and their
sources your honor the intervention rule
as the court is aware allows
intervention uh by anybody uh where the
issue is tremaine to the subject matter
of the proceeding
and certainly your honor the
purported testimony the proper testimony
of a former employee of tmz who
purports to be in a position to disclose
confidential information learned during
the work during the operation of
journalism during his work as a
journalist
is a german issue that is being raised
in this case and your honor we would
point the court to the tafs fletcher
molden and reid versus southern bank and
trust case 213 virginia circuit lexus
253 it's a norfolk circuit court
decision from 2013 and there it was an
interpleader action the funds had been
interplayed into the court by two trust
companies that were fighting
over it
and the the men who had sold his
property who had no interest in the
funds themselves interpl intervened in
the case because he was uncertain as to
his liability for excess funds which was
an issue that was not directly in
litigation between the two parties it
was not part of the cause of action
between the two trusts fighting over the
money that had been pleaded into the
court the circuit court held that
certainly the rights of that man was
going to be affected by the
decision-making in the case he would be
prejudiced if he didn't have an
opportunity to intervene and no party
was in the position to assert his rights
and so similarly hear your honor tmz is
a news organization it routinely accepts
information as is common in journalism
under exchanges of promises of
confidentiality if it is not able to
intervene in this action and neither of
the parties is going to be in a position
to assert the reporter's privilege it is
um w it is tmz's journalist privilege
that we're talking about then the rights
are certainly going to be but if the
witness
in all the cases and i reviewed the
cases that you had in those cases the
witness was compelled to testify and
came
and was forced to testify so there was
an issue about the privilege of the
witness it's my understanding in this
case this witness
wants to testify and is not under
subpoena he has been subpoenaed your
honor
okay
your honor i have a copy of a subpoena
that was injured last night compelling
mr tremaine to give testimony in this
case
and so he is coming under a compulsion
under subpoena and if he takes a stand
and he he searched some sort of
privilege then that's something i will
deal with at that time sure but uh i'm
here because of the scenario where he
may not assert that right exactly and
that's that's
why i'm saying all your cases that you
showed
were the opposite where they did assert
the privilege well it is it is a um a
unique situation right and i understand
you might have some some
issues with a former employee and you
have some avenues to go
um
deal with that um but once once he
testifies in the privileges way we have
lost our opportunity um to intervene and
just intercede all right and you're
under the privilege you know i know your
honor you said you read the case i
appreciate that yes sir but the
privilege it has been recognized by the
virginia supreme court in the brown case
and applied by the circuit courts
uniformly it is a very important
underpinning of the relationship between
reporters and sources and reporters and
the public
without the ability to enforce
its promises
but by current employees or former
employees a news organization will have
absolutely no control
over uh being able to enforce its
promises and so we would ask the court
to permit us to intervene and to to
assert the privilege that belongs to tmz
which is the organization after all your
honor that would be responsible to the
source if this the privilege were waived
all right i understand mr tobin your
argument i appreciate it very much okay
did the parties wish to be heard
a good morning you're after a good
afternoon your honor um
i'd like to begin where your honor began
as a threshold matter the court should
deny tmz's motion to intervene
intervention is not appropriate for the
reasons suggested in your honors
questions
as your honor is well aware
intervention is only appropriate with
leave of court where a third party seeks
to quote
file a pleading to intervene as a
plaintiff or as a defendant to assert
any claim or defense germane to the
subject matter of the proceeding unquote
virginia supreme court rule 3 colon 14.
as mr tobin to his credit is has
conceded
tmz is not asking to file a pleading
it cannot properly categorize itself
either as plaintiff nor defend it and it
seeks to assert no claim or defense
germain to the subject matter of this
action
moreover even if the privilege were
applicable which is not the case here
the testimony intended is directly
relevant and would
outweigh
any qualified privilege quote an
intervener must be asserting an interest
that is part of the subject matter of
the litigation unquote hudson vs jarrett
269 virginia 24 at 32.
here as mr tobin stated tmz seeks to
protect a potential
seeks to protect
potential information solicited from a
third-party witness
which is in no way a matter before this
court citing commonwealth versus gill
89 virginia circuit 323
a 2014 case denying a motion to
intervene where the intervener filed it
quote to protect a property right
not a matter before the court unquote
the outcome of this trial will not
affect tmz and it does not have a
sufficient interest in the subject
matter of this suit to intervene see
texas fletcher maiden and reed pc versus
bank national trust co
23
2013 west law 584
9140
granting uh and this is distinguishing
and granting the motion to intervene
where the interveners liability would be
affected by the outcome
of the litigation
finally your honor tmz lacks standing to
object to testimony by a third party in
this action because tmz as your honor
pointed out is not being compelled to
testify
tmz's reliance on the philip morris case
for the proposition that the privilege
cannot be circumvented by seeking
confidential source information from an
employee is an opposite
36 va circuit at one
for one thing
as noted in that case there is no
testimonial privilege akin to that
enjoyed under the fifth amendment which
would allow a reporter to refuse to
appear before a grand jury and answer
questions
and philip morris as your owner is aware
the party issued
a third party subpoena for records to
trace confidential sources
philip morris is an opposite here
as that case
related
as as this case is is related to witness
testimony
not
records as your honor suggested tmz's
quarrel if any
is with mr tremaine to the extent that
he had an nda that was enforceable
applicable
uh and that's not what we're hearing
from mr tobin so to the extent that tmz
which is not exactly edward r murrow
your honor
uh to the extent they have uh
a beef as it were a cognizable beef it
is with mr it is with mr tremaine it is
not with mr depp
and they clearly do not have standing
uh to assert or to intervene because
they are not intervening as a party
plaintiff or defendant so we
respectfully submit to the extent the
court disagrees i can go into the
argument why the privilege is
inapplicable but i will reserve that
thank you all right yes ma'am
your honor i would like to weigh in from
just a different perspective and that is
because we're trying to deal with some
important issues of privilege etc but
from our perspective representing ms
heard
we have issues with this witness
separately and i want to make them very
clear for the record this is somebody
who should have been identified in
discovery was never
second of all it's not relevant whether
apparently what they're saying he's
going to testify and we have not had the
opportunity to discover that um is he's
going to claim that someone leaked to
tmz that misheard was going to obtain uh
the tro on that friday and also leak the
video that the kitchen video with mr
depp being rather violent um
and
i'm almost certain he's not going to
claim it's misheard so i think it's
never going to come in right mr hoffman
i understand all that do you have any
argument as to this particular motion
my point is though if you balance the
prejudice versus the probative value i i
don't even see how he can come in on
foundation
or relevance that's just not part of
this motion at this time thank you ma'am
all right mr tobin your your motion you
get the last word sir thank you your
honor um
you know i i
appreciate that um the the court
shook your head when he made the snarky
comment that this is not edward r murrow
obviously the first amendment applies to
everybody citizens the new york times or
tmz um and this is a first amendment
based privilege your honor the uh philip
morris case is actually a very good case
to answer your honors question um about
the uh the the intervention of somebody
else in order to assert the privilege um
their uh abc was a defendant in the case
and it moved in order to prevent other
people the phone company but they were
already in the case in that particular i
understand there is no other mechanism
though and so i you know it's it would
be an interesting procedural issue for
peel your honor whether a journalist a
journalism organization or anybody else
who's a first amendment holder would be
denied intervention on a
constitutional-based privilege
i also just for the record and for the
merits of the case if i understood mr
chu correctly he said this is not an
issue in the litigation this does not
relate to an issue in the litigation
well if it's not an issue in the
litigation if it's not part of a prima
facie part of the defense part of the
allegations of the complaint if it's
impeachment evidence if it's collateral
to the main issues in the case under the
brown the commonwealth decision under
the virginia supreme court under the
application of that privilege in the
philip morris versus abc news it is not
supposed to be compelled in this case
which is
again it's not being compelled it
appears well he is appearing by subpoena
and it is a compulsory process and he
will have an obligation unless he
asserts privilege under oath but it is
our privilege your honor it's it's not
an employee a loyal or a rogue
employee's privilege to waive uh on
behalf of its employer this is an
unusual situation
but the law but the answers are there um
in the law and it is it is a first
amendment concern this is not the first
unusual situation in this case i can
for free
mr toad for anybody here yes sir i
appreciate you coming in today and i
appreciate your arguments yes sir thank
you all right in this matter
under uh virginia rule supreme court uh
3 colon 14 a new party may intervene as
a plaintiff or defendant to assert any
claim
or defense germaine to the subject
matter of the proceeding a new party may
not intervene unless they assert some
right involved in the underlying
litigation a party is not entitled to
intervene merely because a byproduct of
the litigation adversely impacts them
and the decision to allow intervention
is within the broad discretion of the
trial court here the rights asserted are
not germaine to the trial the central
issues in this case are whether
defendant defamed plaintiff and whether
plaintiff defamed defendant through a
theory of vicarious liability the issue
of the confidentiality of sources has
not come up
as in other cases cited by ehm which is
the
the corporation that tmz belongs to is
under their umbrella
in brown versus the commonwealth there
was an attempt by the criminal defendant
to subpoena institutions in order to
obtain the name of the confidential
source when the author of the article
was subpoenaed she refused to identify
her confidential source on the stand and
in this case
it appears that the witness is willing
to state
the name of the confidential source
without being compelled voluntarily
whether that breaches a non-disclosure
agreement between mr tremaine and ehm is
not germane to this matter and can be
litigated in a separate matter if ehm so
chooses and while breaches of contract
must be taken seriously and the court
does any alleged breach is not germane
to the underlying litigation here that
contractional action has no bearing on
this case and is thus not germane to
this litigation therefore i'll deny the
non-party hm productions motion to
intervene
thank you honor uh for the record i've
known mr tobin for several years i meant
no snarkiness towards him
you're just a snarky guy
ashley
your honor i am concerned that we
preserve the issue fully um and so for
the record yes for the record and so i i
would ask may i have the opportunity to
object when mr um mr tremaine is
questioned question by question you're
no sir you're not a party to this case
however i will note for your record your
objection to his complete testimony uh
on behalf of your client right thank you
okay thank you
your microphone
as with the hicksville
witness your honor i would ask that we
could voidhear him before the jury um to
find out when he contacted council and
when when they became aware of it and i
think also under the circumstances in
fairness i think we should at least be
able to ask him what he's going to claim
response
your honor i don't think that's
appropriate certainly i don't think a
proffer is necessary or appropriate i'm
not going to do a proper this matter
okay all right
oh oh mr ruttenberg is almost at once i
know i'm so sorry um but truly i truly
am the messenger here because mr murphy
uh just informed me that he has to just
clarify one thing one clarification okay
okay
that's fine i think we need miss myers
all right so court will be in recess
let's come back at two so everybody gets
an hour for lunch okay
all right two o'clock
all right you can have a seat all right
cross examination
thank you your honor
mr depp i'd like to start with the
honeymoon that you and miss hurt took in
late july 2015. surely
you testify that you you took a train
ride from bangkok to singapore is that
right that's correct and you claim that
on this train ride that misheard um hit
you in the face correct
uh yes and left a black eye correct
yes
and
michelle could you please pull up px162
is that already inhabitants yes
you published the church thank you
mr depp this is the picture that your
council showed you both in um your prior
or showed you this morning correct
yes sir okay and that mark under your
left eye is what you claim to be a black
eye caused by misheard correct
um
seems to be there's some scratches
around my nose as well okay
all right but
that it's your your left eye the one
close to the chef that's that's what
you're you says your black eye correct
yes okay
um
and that was the picture your team chose
to show you right
let's pull up exhibit 1905 michelle
please i'm sorry which number was it
this is a new exhibit you're honored
1905. that's defendants
defendants exhibit 1905.
ask for permission to publish your honor
or you want to put it in evidence
okay any objection to 1905
um with the um comments we have no
objection to the photograph itself we
would ask the comments be redacted as
hearsay
well
i'd like to at least question the
witness about
i have no objection to the photograph
being published
okay well then let's let's wait wait a
minute mr deb you see here this
these are four pictures of you right
yes yeah and and below it it they
indicate that they were taken on july
24th
2015 in bangkok thailand correct
objection lack of foundation calls for
speculation
in bangladesh or before the train ride
correct before the train ride because
you didn't get on the train ride until
the 25th is that right
somewhere in that area i guess okay your
honor i'd ask for uh permission to
publish this to the jury
all right
if it's just the photographs we have no
objections all right if you want to
redact the uh
just have the photographs in it sure
we'll do 19. yeah just with redaction
i think there's still some on the bottom
i'm not sure it's just redact though
[Music]
thank you michelle all right publish
thank your honor michelle could you
please
um scroll down to the bottom two
pictures there
mr depp in these pictures that were
taken
before you got
on the train ride for your honeymoon
where you claim that misheard hit you
and gave you a black eye you have the
exact same shadow or sunburner mark
under your left eye
the exact same mark don't you
that's the um
when you get a side light you see the
occipital bone
so
that is the exact area yeah
and it's actually a side leg will cause
that yeah well the picture's not being
taken from the side is it it's being
taken
no no the lens in front yeah light on
the side right will cause
that occipital bone i believe it's
called
to to
appear sunken just like lights on the
side of a train car correct motion calls
for speculation you can take that down
michelle that was in fact in the dark
people on either side of me
i don't see where the light fill is from
the side there mr definitely wait for
the next question next question next
question even the picture your team
chose to show you on that train
isn't accurate is it let's pull up
jackson calls for speculation let's pull
up exhibit 1859 please
1859 is that in evidence no your honor
mr deb this is this this is the same
picture the same
exact same scene
displayed in px 162
that you looked at this morning correct
that
looks
like my face has been the eyes have been
photoshopped oh okay bye so this this
this post from the eastern and oriental
express facebook page you're saying that
that's photoshopped
is that from their page i would sure why
wouldn't they let's pull them up side by
side please
you're on our booth for the admission of
uh this exhibit we can just just have
the pictures we don't need the any
objection to the picture objection lack
of foundation lack of authentication
is that you in the photo mr doubt
it is me but it's clearly your honor
anything after that first of all
um and
would ask for admission of this
photograph
all right just the photograph yeah are
you gonna we maintain our lack of
authentication lack of foundation all
right over objection about 1859 and
thank you your honor michelle could i
please get you
to
you need to redact it first
we actually have have one um
that will admit or ask to be admitted as
1858 uh that is just the picture i
already have each okay so we'll call
this 1859 then
so this is 18.59
yeah we just need to okay
we'll fix that exhibit sticker on the
bottom and get you that
correct 1859
and michelle what i'd like to ask you to
do please is to to put
the picture
displayed as 1859
just
was admitted into evidence next to
px 162 that was shown to mr depp this
morning
okay you can pop those are both in
evidence yeah can you try to make them
the same size please
this is the exact same picture isn't it
mr depp
with radically different quality
and
no you answered my question
i don't know i wasn't done
you answered my question sir thank you
appreciate it you're very welcome
[Music]
mr depp you had that whatever mark it is
whether it's a sunburn whether it's a
shadow whether it's the light reflecting
you had that same mark on your eye
before you got on that train
well it's pretty difficult to sunburn on
the train
um photographs with the child i don't
look particularly sunburned can we see
those again let's let's uh pull up
exhibit uh
one actually no let's let's talk about
australia for a little bit oh good
you testified that you've never done
ecstasy more than a handful of times in
your life correct
seven times now you heard miss heard
testimony you've been sitting i know you
didn't look at her but you heard her
testimony and you heard her you didn't
hear her say you ingested eight to ten
all at once she said she came down after
being apart from you for some time and
there were eight to ten gone from the
bag objection form compound
overbought yes
i also heard mr i reached into a bag and
threw them
poured a bunch of
mdma down my mouth correct correct
that's right she didn't say
10 at one time did she said a handful
okay she's more than 10 i believe okay
the fact is mr depp you are asking for
ecstasy you who have only done it six
times in your life you were asking
asking for ecstasy and cocaine within
minutes of being admitted to the
hospital after suffering your finger
injury weren't you objection compound
i don't recall that i was worried
for any drugs yeah let's pull up the
plaintiffs or exhibit 393 please
you just said you don't recall you were
begging for any drugs no i don't but i
do recall being in great pain in great
distress so okay i could have asked for
a teddy bear as well okay
so this has been this has been admitted
your honor this is an evidence okay you
can publish
and if you can blow up the text please
michelle
in this text message mr death
you were after you suffered your finger
injury you just testified you don't
recall asking for any drugs you're
you're texting nathan holmes your
personal assistant need more whitey
stuff asap brother man and the
e-business now we went over this in your
cross-examination didn't we
if you say solution and you and whitey's
stuff is cocaine
i would say and the e-business is
ecstasy
um you are not quite likely yes okay so
i think i didn't recall that
can you pull up exhibit 1817 please
this is um
a picture that you were showed shown
this morning mr depp
yes and you kind of made some
illustrations on the picture and and
gave your account of what you see here
mr depp you testified previously that
the vodka bottle that you allege
cut off your finger was a handle of
vodka correct
um yes right second bottle there was a
handle on it right yes
this bottle whatever it is to the extent
it's glass at all that's in the corner
of this room that's not a handle of
vodka objection calls for speculation um
i think you'll find that i said two
bottles
well actually what you testified to this
morning mr depp was that the bottle in
the corner was the handle
and there is no other bottle in the
picture is there no that's not what it
testified i testified that may i touch
the screen
yes
this
is glass
this
is glass
and that's not a handle neither of those
are handles of vodka it's that big it's
broken the handles of the top
on those volca bottles sir yeah i mean
and none if you if you combine all that
glass on the floor that doesn't make up
the amount of glass and a handle of
vodka does it objection calls for
speculation
there's objection hold on i'll sustain
the objection next question there is no
picture of a handle of vodka broken on
that floor is there mr depp
no i don't see it i see glass under this
chair here okay well
you tell this morning that you did see
it so it's good to get that
clarification no i didn't say this
you also testified this morning that
you
yeah and i want to get this i want to
make sure that we're we're on the same
page here you testified earlier this
morning that there was no phone in the
bar area downstairs is that what you
testified to
uh
i don't recall the phone in the bar area
okay i don't recall i don't recall a
bakelite phone in the bar area where i
okay
let's let's pull up um michelle please
the uk day three
page 421 mr deb
we've
we've done this drill before this is
your testimony from the uk correct
can i please have
it's this we don't have copies for
everyone that's on the screen your honor
please i would like to have
what
he's the testimony of the wicked you can
have my copy
mr deb you remember giving testimony in
the uk trial for several days correct
okay so yeah okay here yeah so that i do
remember a telephone in the bar area
this is my turn to do this mr dow i'm
sorry
on page 421 line
you were asked the question and this
telephone that you picked up was made of
i'm sorry i'm going to go go up one the
line 15.
question at one stage when you were in
the kitchen screaming ms heard you
picked up a wall mounted telephone do
you remember a telephone in the kitchen
answer no ma'am i remember a telephone
in the bar area
question and this telephone that you
picked up was made of bakelite do you
know what i mean by that a retro
telephone wall mounted but retro
answer it was a wall mounted telephone
but it was not bakelite it was a modern
phone it was plastic
question
a phone that was a wall-mounted phone
that was picked up can you scroll down
please
question a phone that was a wall-mounted
phone that was picked up by you held in
your right hand and you were repeatedly
smashing it against the wall in your
right hand answer that is possible
but i do not if that is the case i do
not believe i spent very much time on
the phone i remember ripping the phone
off the wall that was your testimony
correct
it seems it would be yes thank you i
answered my question thank you
mr depp you've you've claimed before
you've said if i'm angry and i've got to
lash out or hit somebody i'm going to do
it and i don't care what the
repercussions are anger doesn't pay rent
it's got to go it's got to be evicted
you've said that before haven't you
have you a quote from me somewhere
saying that
it's my question to you you've said that
before haven't you well actually let's
refresh your recollection can you pull
up um
it goes in the machine article please
possibly about paparazzi's
mr deb you see that picture of you
um on the lower left
usually shirtless and wearing a crown
i believe that you see the long
paragraph above that that starts with
in the mark hotel
and at the bottom of that
does this refresh your recollection that
you said
i have a lot of love inside me and a lot
of anger inside me as well
if i love somebody then i'm going to
love them
if i'm angry and i've got to lash out or
hit somebody i'm going to do it and i
don't care what the repercussions are
anger doesn't pay rent it's got to go
it's got to be evicted
do i read that right
you did read that right yes thank you
you can take that down michelle please
now
mr deb you've also
claimed that um
you've said before that if if you want
to be with a woman sexually that she is
rightfully yours
haven't
you could you repeat that and you've
also said that could you repeat that
please yeah that if you want to be with
a woman sexually that she is rightfully
yours
that's ludicrous
you've also said that with respect to
women that you want to be with you've
remarked i need i want i take haven't
you
equally as ludicrous no can you pull up
dx883 please
you can pull it what you like i've never
showed those words
there's not enough hubris in
me to say anything eight three eight
eight three your honor it's not just is
it evidence it is not admitted yet okay
mr depp
these are text messages from you
to stephen duders on february 22 2017
correct um
this
no this looks nothing like me you might
have mistaken uh
mr depp we can show the full unredacted
you've looked at a number of text
messages in this case and the words him
as the identifier that's you correct in
every text message we've seen in this
case
yeah
sure it still doesn't mean it hasn't
been screwed with
that's not
anything
that i've ever said or written you want
to see the whole the whole thing
unredacted we can look at that too no
because you could have typed it up last
night no
i can assure you i didn't type it up
last night mr depp your honor i'd move
for the admission of exhibit 883 all
right any objection uh objection on
relevance grounds your honor all right
let's do our approach for a moment
all right 883 and evidence as redacted
thank you mr depp are you you're aware
these are text messages
you can see the bottom right where it
says death and then it has a number
eight one two nine those are produced by
you in this litigation you understand
that right i understand that's great all
right michelle could you please
let's take a look at the top text first
mr depp on february 22nd 2017
you texted mr duders right
exactly
molly's [ __ ] is rightfully mine
should i not just bust in and remove its
hinges tonight
did i read that right
you read it right and the one beneath
that
you say
i want to change her understanding
of what it is like to be thrashed about
like a pleading mackerel and then in all
caps you write i need
i want
i take
did i read that right you read it right
but i did not write that okay
perhaps you wrote every
that you produced that came from you in
this litigation didn't you not
necessarily sometimes you give your
people your phone to people and they
when you got off that plane excuse me
from boston that's right when you got
off the plane from boston you you knew
miss hurd was angry with you didn't you
it was pretty much objection calls for
speculation and
you understood her to be angry right
she was always angry yes and you asked
mr deuters same person you can take this
down michelle please thank you same
person that you texted that last exhibit
you asked mr deuters to
communicate with her on your behalf
correct
um i don't know what you're talking
about you'd have to explain you asked mr
deuters to
communicate with miss heard by text
to speak to her about the incident
correct
about what incident
to speak to her about the plane flight
the plane plane
the boston plane
the boston plane
so you're saying that i
uh
influenced mr deuters i told him that he
had to write this and i had told me how
to write that is that which no no it
wasn't uncommon for mr deuters to text
to to communicate with mr on your behalf
correct objection calls for speculation
um oh he was your personal assistant mr
dudes was your personal assistant
correct i have two personal assistants
at the time he was one of them right
yeah mr dudes was one of them yesterday
right and and it wasn't uncommon for you
to ask mr deuters to communicate with
miss hurt on your behalf correct
um
it wasn't uncommon for any of them to
communicate
with monsieur on my behalf if i were on
set
or or
unavailable or
any of that or if or if misheard and you
had had a fight you would sometimes have
them to communicate with miss hurt on
your behalf correct
i think my crew caught on very quickly
that just just would be
necessary for them to know just the yes
or no it was not uncommon after you and
mr had i'd asked that he'd be allowed to
finish his answer yes or no question all
right
can i ask your question thank you it
wasn't uncommon for you to have
one of your personal assistants
communicate with miss heard after you
and her had a fight
i disagree because you're insinuating
that i had them do it and you don't know
that
after the boston plane flight you had mr
deuters
communicate with miss heard correct
when i'm asked what to do i should play
a case or just play cater like we always
do and and you you
told him
send her whatever message you need to
send i'm sorry he's sorry he feels bad
yes because
any other
answer
you know
it would turn into world war three okay
can you pull up exhibit 229 please
you're on all right
i think you know where i'm going here
and based on mr depp's testimony i'd ask
for the admission of exhibit 229. your
honor
can we please report
mr deb you
you were pretty angry after miss heard
got her temporary restraining order
weren't you
angry i was more than anything i was
hurt
and you testified earlier this morning
you claim that you
you somehow were responsible for her
getting the role uh with warner brothers
correct
that's what you testified to this
morning you also
you also tried to get her fired
from aquaman didn't you
after the temporary restraining order
which question would you like me to
handle first one question sir you tried
to get her fired from the aquaman after
the temporary restraining order didn't
you um well what is related to the story
about me it just yes yes or no mr depp i
i don't i didn't
i can't please you with a yes or no
every single time that's a yes or no
question mr jeff you tried to get
misheard fire didn't you answer's no all
right let's pull up um exhibit 821
is that is this fire
this is a
this is a text message that you had with
your sister kristy dembrowski she's the
first witness in this case right she
doesn't work at warren brothers she
can't fire amber
this is a text message you had with her
on june 4th 2016. isn't it
june 12 yes
your honor uh move for the admission of
exhibit 821 is redacted any objection
um
we would object on relevance grounds
your honor
i overrule that objection 821 in
evidence
and on june 4th
2016
mr depp you texted your sister i want
her replaced on that wb film
did i read that right
you did her is referring to amber right
that's correct and wb is warner brothers
correct
again correct yes and then after you
sent this text to your sister
following the temporary restraining
order you reached out to guy silverstein
to have him fire amber correct
greg silverstein i'm sorry
um
i don't recall reaching out to greg
silverstein you reached out to sue crawl
right i had vetted miss hurt
and
i i had vetted miss herrera mr jeff you
got your chances
your honor one of those two friends
should definitely just answer the
question sir next question you reached
out to greg silverstein to get him to to
try to get amber fire from aquaman
didn't you
mention
excuse me aston answered
it's a yesterday question that he hasn't
answered yesterday all right
yes or no sir you reached out to greg
silverstein to try to get amber fired
from aquaman
second half of your question is wrong
sir you reached out to her because i
vetted her no no mr depp you reach out
to sue crawl to get her to to try to get
her to
help you get amber fired from aquaman
didn't you
no and you reached out to kevin suzahara
to try to get him to help you get amber
fired from aquaman didn't you no
can you pull up exhibit 857 please
mr depp this is a text message that you
sent to christian carino
on august 15 2016. correct this this is
already in evidence correct
parts of it oh so not this not this
version well this can't be 857 then
don't don't
i'm sorry your honor i understood um
eight we'll call it 857a
857.
okay
all right yes sir thank you my apologies
your honor
mr deb you sent this text to christian
carino on it august 15th i most
certainly did okay
and
in this text that you sent to chris you
know christian carino is the person who
used to be amber's agent and then was
your agent for a time correct
that is correct
and in this text
you
oh you're on a permission to publish
please do you want to put in evidence
yeah first move for admission of 857 a
objection no objection all right 8 57 a
as redacted we'll be in evidence
thank you honor and in this text mr depp
you said she's begging for total global
humiliation
she's gonna get it
i'm gonna need your texts about san
francisco brother
i'm even sorry to ask but she sucked
mollusk's crooked dick and he gave her
some shitty lawyers
i have no mercy
no fear and not an ounce of emotion
or what i once thought was love for this
gold-digging level dime a dozen mushy
pointless dangling overused flappy fish
market
i'm so [ __ ] happy she wants to go to
fight this out she will hit the wall
hard
and i cannot wait to have this waste of
a [ __ ] guzzler out of my life
i met a [ __ ] sublime little russian
here which made me realize the time i
blew on that 50 cent stripper i wouldn't
touch her with a goddamn glove
i can only hope that karma kicks in and
takes the gift of breath from her
sorry man but now i will stop at nothing
let's see if mollusk has a pair
come see me face to face i'll show him
things he's never seen before
like the other side of his dick when i
slice it off
did i read that right you did
now
not long after this you can take that
down michelle thank you not long after
this miss you you met mr waldman in the
late summer fall of 2016. correct
i believe yeah september october
somewhere in there whatever and he's
been your attorney since then correct
yes sir
and you met with him
with
the daily mail in london in february
2020 didn't you
i'm sorry again you and mr waldman
together met with the daily mail in
london in february 2020 didn't you
um
are you asking
me a question
about my attorney and i
[Music]
yeah that you two met with people from
the daily mail in london in february
2020.
was that during the
london trial
no
no
no
in february i don't recall it though
okay
to the extent mr waldman testified that
you did you you don't dispute that
correct i just don't i don't i don't
recall it okay you don't disagree with
mr waldman's testimony that you and he
met with people from the daily mail in
london in february 2020 correct
if that's mr waldman's testimony then
but i just didn't necessarily know who
these people were right
i guess the same month that the daily
mail released
a alleged tapes between you and amber
objection calls for speculation
personal knowledge across the state i'll
sustain the objection next question
now mr depp
you you testified and i wrote it down
before lunch you said
when miss myers asked you something
about you know how does it feel to make
you or how does it feel to be here you
said i've been living with it for six
years
and waiting to be able to get the truth
out remember saying that
yes you also said
i've spoken up for what i've been
carrying on my back
something to that effect you remember
saying that
yes and you've claimed several times in
this proceeding mr deb that this trial
is your first chance to tell your story
haven't you
yes sir
but that's just not true is it mr deb
that's not true
that's
no for me it is true okay well
here's the thing you you
the fact is mr depp
when dan wooten wrote an article that
was published in the sun calling you a
wife beater you brought a lawsuit
against the sun in june of 2018 correct
yes and that was that was six months
before miss heard ever wrote her op-ed
correct
i don't know
and in the summer of 2020
there was a several week trial in london
against the sun
correct
mr was not a party to that trial not my
question mr depp in the article that the
son wrote that you sued over
you sued
for mr wooten calling you a wife beater
correct
objection asked and answered sustained
next question
and in the trial that you subsequently
brought
you called a lot of witnesses right
i don't know what a lot is i don't know
many people testified
on both sides of the trial correct yes
many people and
many exhibits were introduced correct
like a trial yes and you just like in
this trial you were on the stand for
several days in that trial correct
yes
and
that trial involved the same factual
issues that you are litigating here
which is whether you actually made a
domestic abuse
amber hurt sustain the objection next
question you brought that case against
the sun
because you
were angry at the sun we're calling you
a wife beater correct
yeah that's
probably a pretty good reason and you
went through that trial in london
correct i didn't do yes mr deb you've
already had a chance to tell your story
haven't you
let me bring limitations
in the uk trial okay no further
questions all right redirect thank you
mr deb um mr rottenborn asked you some
questions about um
the uk trial
why do you feel that this is the first
time that you've actually had an
opportunity to tell your story and as
you said get off get the load off your
back
as as the uk trial
was
me suing
dan wooten and the son for defamation
for calling me
um
a wife beater
um
the uk have different while there are
different laws there are different ways
they handle things there are also
limitations
in
uh
evidence
um
some things can be brought up some
things cannot be brought
he's up about
limitations and evidence in the english
he's talking about his experience
testifying overruled him
you'll be okay
um
yes the
there is a very
um
everything is quite boxed in
with regard to with regard to what can
be said what can be spoken about so
uh
ms heard provided information to the
sun
as their star witness
but the
case was not brought against
miss
newspaper
journal whatever it is
uh mr rottenborn reference that you were
on the stand for
multiple days
four and a half i believe yes yeah what
was the
nature of that examination excuse me who
was conducting that examination of you
um
qc sasha wass
and whose attorney was that the sons
can we please pull up dx
857-a
all right it's already in evidence you
can
publish it
mr duff do you recall seeing this text
message
when mr rottenborn was questioning you
oh yes i do
can you explain what you're conveying to
mr carino in this text message
i mean
i'm in total
shock that this is happening to me that
my
entire
life on the planet
has been brought to the head of a pen
with all this
um
completely
utterly false information so i am
yeah when you're accused of
horrific acts and things that you have
not done
when it's actually
some
very
uh
ugly
things that are going out there into the
world about you
on a non-stop basis
by miss herd and her team
you have a tendency
as humans
to get very very
irate
and angry
not to the point where you go out and
hurt someone
not to the point even where you
assault a cabinet
but
you do get irate
you do wonder
why this person is doing this to me
so yeah many things go through your head
um
and then you've got your family you've
got your kids you've got your parents
my mom thankfully
didn't get to read any of this because
that would have killed her
but my father my
my family my
everyone that i've met the people that
supported me suddenly i'm
scum
and why
never had to happen
one little lie
so yes
very angry
could we please pull up defendants
exhibit 821
mr depp do you recall seeing this
text message
um when mr rottenborn was asking
questions yes he loves this one yes yes
would you care to explain
what you're trying to convey in this
text message
um
[Music]
well
warner brothers
was about to find they were about to
find themselves in quite a dilemma
as
the person that they had just cast
objection your honor lack of foundation
as to what warner brothers knew or
thought didn't i meet with him all right
we could just wait uh for the question
uh i'll sustain the objection next
question
um mr deb without explaining what
warner brothers felt
why did you send this text message to
your sister
and what excuse me strike that what were
you trying to convey to your sister when
you sent this text message
honestly i felt responsibility for
having gone to those people
and and and and you know uh
painted such a beautiful projection
here say your honor now he's talking
about what he said to warner brothers
please continue
you change seats
so sorry you can continue
um
i i felt it was my responsibility
to get
the truth to warner brothers
about they were going to what they were
going to end up facing down the line
which is two franchises
that would be
would be causing problems for one
another especially as
all the
any any news any press any media that
came out about me at that time had been
turned into you know i was charles
manson you know i was
the worst thing on on earth and they
just kept coming it was like a
it was like a non-stop fire
so
my responsibility
after having painted a beautiful picture
of her for them was to tell them
um
[Music]
i uh i think you better objection your
honor
getting into what he claims he told
warner brothers or wanted to he's he's
saying what he he wanted to tell them
he's not saying what he actually told
them sustain objection next question
mr depp you mentioned two franchise
films with warner brothers what two
franchise films are you referring to um
there was aquanet i mean aquaman sorry
aquaman and fan
fantastic beasts
the one that i was
in
and why did you
feel a responsibility with respect to
those two franchise films
um
warner brothers was starting to get
quite
upset about
some of the things that were being said
about me in the press that were constant
constant constant
hit pieces
um
and
[Music]
you know
on one level on one level
yes it's just acting it's just movies
but it's business
and it's your word
and i've given my word to them
and i had to i felt
responsible in it to be that i had to
tell them
exactly what was going on
and
that it was going to end up ugly
and which of those two film franchises
were you a part of i'm sorry which of
those two film franchises were you a
part of
um i was uh
i was i was in a fantastic beasts
and where to find them and i was in um
the fantastic beastly crimes of
grindelwald
could we please pull up dx883
now mr duff do you recall seeing these
text messages during mr ronborne's
examination
oh god yeah yes i remember
and you didn't seem to recall
these text messages is that fair
it truly truly is
fair it's i mean it's not i'm not
do yeah knows i don't know who molly is
i don't know any i don't know nothing
about this
do you have any understanding of what
you're referring to in this text message
are these two text messages no
i i honestly if if somebody else had
borrowed my phone or something and made
this text to stephen possibly
but i don't understand
the
i don't i don't have that kind of uh
i don't write like i don't have that
kind of hubris or
uh
expectation that's quite grotesque
text
can we take that down please
can we please pull up defendants exhibit
1821
mr
dub do you recognize this document
that is behind the bar yes
okay and do you see it
mr ronborne asked you some questions
about whether there was a telephone yes
i see a telephone there now
and
did you recall that telephone being
there
i don't recall the telephone being there
but uh i can see it now
can we please pull up eight uh
defendants exhibit 1820
do you recall me showing you this text
message earlier on
uh
or excuse me do you recall me showing
you this picture
uh during your examination yes yes yeah
okay
and
i think i asked you
whether you recall a phone being mounted
on the wall in the left of this picture
do you remember that
yes and what was your answer to that no
mr depp
mr roddenborn asked you some questions
about your your honeymoon do you
remember that
yes and i believe you had testified that
you and miss heard were on the orient
express together that's correct yes
where had you been prior to
being on the orient express
we had been in
australia
and then made it over to
thailand to catch the
orient express
um if we could bring up the plaintiff's
exhibit 162 again
mr depp do you know who took this
picture
malcolm connolly
and
despite what mr rottenborn and showed
you about the of the picture of you
prior to this
do you see a bruise on your face in this
picture um
i see like what looks like a pretty
decent shiner and kind of a scratched up
nose yes
and do you recall how you got the
scratches and the shiner
there was a very brief um
freak out that miss hurd had in our
cabin
uh just before this dinner
i can't remember why
there were many
um
i remember taking the photograph though
i mean i remember being there i remember
meeting the chef and
but i
i mean
the quality of the photos not great
the quality of the other folia that he
shows has been
pretty pretty dope
mr deb did you ever
physically abuse miss her during your
relationship never
never
no further questions all right sure you
can have a seat next to your attorneys
thank you thank you very much
thank you
your next witness
didn't quite get that i'm sorry
mr dab calls morgan tremaine
all right morgan tremaine
so
do you solely swear or testify
truthfully in this case
good afternoon mr tremaine hello
would you please state your full name
for the record morgan cliff tremaine
and what do you do for a living
i produce esports events and design
video games
and in 2016 what did you do for a living
i worked as the field assignment manager
at tmz
what is tmz tmz isn't
an entertainment news
website and television show
and what were your responsibilities as a
field assignment manager for tmz
uh i was the go between the news desk in
the office and the reporters in the
field which you might know as paparazzi
approximately how many paparazzis were
you in charge of
uh at the time it was about 20 in la
a handful maybe three in new york and
then one in dc
and what were your responsibilities
specifically as to the paparazzi it
would be to dispatch um paparazzi to
various locations
based on tips
or um
just direction um dictated by having a
list of sort of hot spots where
celebrities would be
and how were those tips received they
were received either through
tips that we received through our tip
line or directly through
news producers in the office
and were tits frequently received
directly from sources
um very often the case yeah
and who were the type of sources that
tmc
received tips from um they would receive
tips from oftentimes it would be
publicists
managers agents or b-list
celebrities
lawyers
and lawyers definitely
how are tips verified
tips are verified um by the extensive
process if they come in through our tip
line we have to verify who sent it that
they um that the source is truthful and
so they have to add their contact
information which is a field in that
on that website for like name uh phone
number
things like that and how long did that
process typically take if we receive a
tip through the tip line um it could
take a while because
that would need to be if it was a tip we
would need to verify it if it was media
such as photos or videos that would need
to be extensively verified to ensure
that the person sending it is the
copyright holder and that we would have
the legal ability to air it and
distribute it
and while working for tmz were you
involved in any assignments related to
ms heard i was
what was the first time you recall
working on an assignment related to ms
heard i believe it was may 27 2016.
and what was your role in that
assignment
for that
ms heard was filing a
restraining order at a courthouse in
downtown los angeles so um i dispatched
camera people to that location
under what circumstances would you
normally send paparazzi to a courthouse
only if we had been informed prior it's
not by any means a celebrity hot spot um
we would only ever send people there if
we had been tipped off that something
was occurring and there was somebody
present there
and what footage was tnc trying to
capture at the la courthouse on may 27
2016. we were trying to capture uh amber
leaving the courthouse
and an alleged bruise on the right side
of her face
what was your team of paparazzi supposed
to do while they were at the la court
house on may 27th 2016. objection your
honor uh hearsay
and foundation what were they supposed
to do right she's asking for i i i don't
think there's a foundation
i'll overrule the objection at this
point
go ahead mr tremaine can you re uh state
the question again what was your team of
paparazzi supposed to do while they were
at the los angeles courthouse on may 27
2016. their objective was to capture her
leaving the courthouse
and then
she was going to sort of stop and turn
towards the camera to display the bruise
on the right side of her face deal edge
bruce
did your team of videographers get the
shot of amber heard we did
what is the difference between receiving
a tip from a news producer at any other
source
if it's any other source it would have
to be verified
by copyright if it was anything that
was received
directly through a news producer then
they go through that process
to verify the source
did you do anything to verify the tip on
may 27 2016 related to amber heard i did
not
why not
because it had come directly from a news
producer
does that mean it had been verified
it means that they had verified that tip
and deemed that it was credible and
therefore a camera person needed to be
dispatched
after may 27 2016 were you involved in
any other assignments related to amber
heard yes
can you tell me about those assignments
um the next one would have been august
6th 2016 where she was giving a
deposition
so what did you do in relation to
that tip
i uh dispatched camera people to a
parking lot adjacent to a law office
in which she would be arriving to
so we could get the footage of her
arriving for the deposition do you
typically send paparazzi's to parking
lots of law offices no not at all
did you get the shot of misheard on
august 6 2016 we did
after august 6 2016
were you involved in any other stories
involving this hurd yes i was
and what story was that
on the 12th we received a video
depicting
johnny depp
slamming some cabinets that was captured
by miss hurt
and what day was that i believe that was
the august 12th of 2016 2016 yes
can you describe to the jury how you
received the video on august 12 2016
yes the video was sent in through our
email tip line
which is an email
distribution that goes to all the
producers and to myself as the field
assignment manager because it often
included celebrity locations
the it came in as as i recall a
objection hearsay
he's just describing how it came in he's
i think he's about to reveal hearsay
your overrule for now we'll see where it
goes
please continue
so i received that email and included a
link
from
some unknown dropbox type um
public uh website in which it continues
your honor here say he's about to
describe what's what comes from the
dropbox website and that's so far as you
said he's uh was a link from the dropbox
we'll see the next question go ahead
next question
so you received a link what was in that
link in that link was the video
of
johnny depp smashing the cabinets
okay
and you received this video in your
inbox correct i did
what did you do once you received that
video
um
we downloaded it we alerted the web
editor who was sitting next to me at the
time
we downloaded it and then were
instructed by the
news producer to do what we call slap
bumpers and a bug on it which is putting
the
at the beginning end and then putting a
translucent watermark over it which
indicates copyright ownership
after you did that was it posted
it was posted yes where was it posted it
was posted to tmz.com
did you do anything else related to
amber heard on august 12 2016
um yes i received a tip that amber heard
would be arriving at lax and so i
dispatched camera people to uh film that
exit or her um her arrival to lax rather
and why did you do that
um i was instructed to
how long does it take to post a story
after
media has been received by tmz after
media has been received
it could take any length of time
depending on
who owns the copyright
how does tmz obtain copyright over
images and videos
um the only way to obtain copyright over
media would be if we shot it ourselves
if it was
sent to the tip line source verified
that it was from the original copyright
owner and then either purchased from
that person or given to us and then the
third option would be if it was directly
given to us by the copyright holder like
a direct source
and how long does it take to copyright
something tmc has received through the
tip line
it can take a while because you have to
extensively verify that that person owns
the copyright
and then possibly it depends also if
they you can even get in contact with
the person because they might not be
super responsive immediately
via phone or email that they provided
and then potentially you'd have to enter
negotiation with our clips and
clearances department to figure out the
cost of that media
how long does it take for tmz to obtain
a copyright or something received
directly from a source
something in the realm of 15 minutes
just to
do what i described before which is
putting bumpers and a bug on something
and write the article and post it it's
pretty fast
how much time had passed from the time
you received the kitchen cabinet video
to the time it was posted on tmz about
15 minutes
did any other tabloids other than tmz
post this video objective the leading
and calls for hearsay did any other
tablets overrule
mr tremaine go ahead
no they did not and why not um because
it was a tmz exclusive
and what does that mean it means the tmz
owns the copyright to it
so it can't be distributed by any other
media source without back linking to tmz
and they wouldn't be able to upload that
media without getting a copyright strike
have you seen the kitchen cabinet video
that was played in this trial i have yes
how does that video
that was played in this trial compared
to the one you received on august 12
2016
um when i had clicked the direct link
that we received and watched the video
in its entirety it was much shorter than
the video we had received than the video
that's been played in this trial there
was some a bit at the beginning that was
played here in which ms heard is
um seemingly sort of sitting at the
camera and getting into position and
then there's a bit at the end where
she's seemingly snickering and looks at
the camera that part was
not present in what we received
did tmz edit the video no not even a
little
when we receive something and it's
edited
there's a clear indicator because
there's sort of a journalistic practice
that uses when there's an edit you do
what's called like a white flash
transition which covers the entire
screen with white to very clearly
indicate to everybody there was an edit
here for time or whatever um just for to
make it a little more compelling but in
this case it was not edited
as i was staring at the machine and
edited it and present for the entirety
of receipt to publishing
when was the next time you worked on an
assignment related to amber heard
um it was
well there was the time we went to the
airport and then the day after that
because she had flown in for the
deposition like i think the first time
didn't work out and so she was arriving
again for the deposition in that same um
parking lot adjacent to a um a law
office and what's that august 13th 2016.
that was august 13th yeah
and what was your assignment on august
13th 2016 uh to dispatch camera people
to that parking lot at a specific time
in order to
film amber heard arriving for the
deposition
how did you know that tip was legitimate
uh it came from a news producer
while you worked at tmz did you ever
receive any communications from mr depp
or his camp i did not
nothing further cross examination
yes
uh so
how do you know
what
video was shown at this trial
um i was alerted by a friend that um
that tmz was being kind of talked about
in this trial and so i had seen a clip
of that
okay so you watched some of this trap
correct
okay when did you first reach out to
counsel for mr depp
um i believe that was six days ago
whatever that date would be i'd have to
do that right and then
you
received a subpoena i think yesterday in
care of your attorney cindy hickox right
correct okay and cindy hickox represents
christy dombrowski kate james robin baum
objection
were you aware of speculation overruled
were you aware of that no
okay
now
if you don't have information that's
helpful to this case
then you wouldn't be a witness correct
objection culture speculation
sustained sustained next question
okay you know this that you know this
case is being televised right i am aware
that there are cameras and so this gets
you your 15 minutes of fame objection
your honor are you mentative i i can ask
that question oh ruled
um
so i stand to gain nothing from this i'm
actually putting myself kind of in a
target of tmz a very litigious
uh organization
and i'm not seeking any 15 minutes here
though you may you're welcome to
speculate i could say the same thing by
taking amber hurt as a client for you
a little argumentative don't you think
oh hardly i find that to be purely
logical thank you now are you aware that
mr depp's attorneys were well aware of
the tro that was going to be presented
on may 27th objection calls for
speculation were you aware of that lack
of foundation
overworld if you can answer it can you
restate the question were you aware that
mr depp's divorce attorneys were aware
that amber heard was going in to see the
tro on may 27.
i don't think i understand the question
i don't think so now
okay do you know
whether blair burke one of mr depp's
divorce attorneys has a very close had a
very close relationship with tmz at that
time objection calls for speculation
overruled
if he knows
i was not aware of that okay and
when you said that you were dispatched
twice once to film amber for in the
parking lot for the deposition and then
it didn't work out and so you had to do
it another time
how did you know it didn't work out
because tmz.com posted an article saying
as much okay no i was not dispatched do
you know why the deposition did not work
out i'd have to reference the article i
forget
so do you i i didn't write that story i
wasn't involved in the actual naturalism
which side
do you know which side would have known
or not known whether that deposition was
going to work out in other words the
people representing mr depp or the
people representing him is hurt i
wouldn't know okay
and then the video clip
you don't know
who provided that correct correct okay
not just to find another one all right
redirect
mr tremaine why did you contact
me
in relation to this case
um i
saw that there was
a discrepancy with like the video that
was shown here in the video that i know
i've received so i i had no interest in
testifying it was i had reached out
simply to maybe try to help with the
timeline of things
or or help with
the case in any way just by virtue of
understanding the timeline of the
stories that were published and kind of
how that can be unclear
but i had no idea i'd be on the stand
nothing further thank you all right sir
you're free to go thank you
all right
you have another witness
okay
mr dev calls brian knew my story your
honor all right try new moisture
here's not much more
this only square or found to testify
truthfully in this case the penalty of
law
yes ma'am
good afternoon mr newmeister good
afternoon could you please state your
full name for the record it's norbert
n-o-r-b-e-r-t
brian i go by brian b-r-y-a-n
newmeister n-e-u-m-e-i-s-t-e-r
um could you start by describing
describing your educational background
please
my educational background well i
graduated from cal state university in
northridge 42 years ago
with a degree in political science
from then on i've been working
professionally in photography totally
unrelated
for the past 42 years
and that would also include videography
audio and a few other different
binary related tasks
where do you currently work
i own usa forensic
what is usa forensic usa forensic is a
digital forensics company we are
boutique we're very small we work
we have offices in growth point farms
michigan and in phoenix arizona
we work with varying types of clients
because to us data is data it takes no
side
so we can be ending up working for
prosecution
defense
law enforcement the innocence project
we have a contract with the department
of defense we do classified and
unclassified work
we've done classified work
with
various agencies
we've worked with doj and i've worked in
23 countries as a photographer
what's your title at usa forensic ceo
did you also found usa forensic
originally in around 1990 it was called
skymeister and
that is because of my they got a
helicopter photography time i have
uh
about 20 about 10 years ago we changed
it to usa forensic while still doing a
lot of the same tasks
and you described i think some of the
entities that you work with um what kind
of work do you do for those entities
that you mentioned we do uh audio
forensics which is clarifying audio for
example sting operations or
audio that may have been picked up on
surveillance or any other type of
recording
removing background sounds
video clarification we do a lot of work
with axon
checked on relevance based on the
discussion we had earlier this
experience has absolutely nothing to do
with anything all right do you have an
objection to him being moved in as an
expert in the field well she hasn't
moved yet i'm objecting to the relevance
of the testimony on the subject matter
right now i'll overrule the objection
thank you your honor
go ahead and stream my story you can
continue
uh where i left off is
we do a lot of work with axon police
cameras because they don't
really handle
low lux levels or low light levels very
well so we clean up uh we are beta
testers for a program called input ace
which is a part of the axon company used
by police officers we clarified their
cameras to better see what happened at
night
for example in in different scenes we do
the same with surveillance cameras
any kind of camera cell phone cameras we
also do uh cell phone forensics
computer forensics and cell tower
forensics along with photograph uh photo
photographic forensics what types of
cases do you work on
it can be anything from a fortune 500s
to um
it can be anything from a pro pro which
is a person that's actually just
representing themselves
in a in a smaller case to a lot of
homicide cases
defamation
it could be any kind of case that
requires cell phone extractions or
computer extractions could be money
laundering could be
a department of defense
identifying a voice that type of thing
satellite imagery
basically anything with binary
information
have you been retained as an expert
before oh yes um i would say
we average about 150 to 200 cases a year
in the last four years we've done over
600 cases
and that would be in uh
u.s federal courts u.s district courts
various state courts throughout
throughout the united states we just
wrapped up a case that was an overseas
case wrapped up yesterday
we do u.s military court
we have a case coming up in front of the
u.s supreme court so it's really very
i've done quite a few u.s district court
cases
have you testified as an expert in
digital forensics before yes um and what
people sometimes don't understand is
only about two percent of all cases go
to trial
so
98 of the time you're actually just
doing the forensic work and giving it to
the parties and as we say
data is data it really doesn't take a
side we don't have a narrative
so very often it's just providing the
data for the attorneys to work with uh
or the parties
have you ever been excluded from
testifying as an expert regarding any
work that you performed
no
but you have to take into account that
sometimes there might be curbs put on
what uh for example in this trial um
there's
certain boundaries
uh or if you're working with a pro per
or
with a attorney that is not very
familiar with
electronics and and the thing is again
they teach
latin and law school not binary and
binary is the universal language these
days so sometimes in the legal system
it's a little bit hard to explain to
attorneys
what exactly we're doing so we try to
break it down and make that work
what is digital forensics digital
forensics is anything that you are using
like your your television set your cell
phone your computer
anything that runs off of binary
information that has coding in it
how long have you worked in digital
forensics well i actually started off an
analog so it's been 40 some odd years i
started off as a cameraman
my first cameras were film cameras when
i was a kid my dad was a director of
sales and sales service administration
for the nbc television network on the
west coast
so i grew up around television cameras
my first cameras were
cameras people might not have heard of
leica hostel blood cameras like that i
trained with some of the best
photographers around at the time william
walner niall latham really excellent
photographers
and
i started shooting videotape from
helicopters and i logged about 14 700
hours of video and
at that time oddly enough since we were
the only
helicopter a television helicopter and
they were the only helicopter in phoenix
at the time the sheriff's the sheriff's
department did not have a helicopter
the police department did not have a
helicopter nor did aravac so we ended up
doubling up
being a news crew as well as an air
rescue career
so as far as forensics analog probably
from 1980 to 1990 and digital from 1990
through current
how'd you get started in it really by
osmosis i started in the production
field i usually don't
do that much tv work anymore i did do
i did shoot part of an episode a program
called planet earth for the bbc last
year
i don't normally do television anymore
it's just 99 forensics
but
i got started because very often as
working in the helicopter
we'd be asked to
work for a police department in a rescue
or a chase or whatever the situation
might be
and since i'd be
videotaping it
they would ask me to break it down frame
by frame and analyzing it using what's
called a time based corrector in the day
and so um word got out that i could do
unusual things because
i'm pretty good with machines
and uh
it
it just ended up it more and more people
started calling and it just became a
full-time job
have you received any professional
certifications in forensics yes but
again
most hackers and people who do
interesting work
don't have any certifications because
the certification is usually like a
week-long course i've been doing this
stuff 42 years um
my partner matt erickson he uh he's
actually a uh objection your honor to
the partner who's not testifying to
those qualifications on relevance
sustained ejection mr newmeister can you
just describe which professional
certifications you have received uh for
uh cell phones uh oxygen
which is a
program similar to silverite
uh but these are these are programs that
are used by law enforcement and by
private parties to extract data from
cell phones
um that has been deleted or
which is critical in a lot of cases
deleted data or just to what we call
image a cell phone in other words get
every bit of data that's possible on a
cell phone and again every cell phone is
different
the next would be in self hour cell
tower forensics
are you a member of any professional
associations in your field yes um the
ieee which is the international
engineering society and the reason i
belong to that
is about 40 of the world's white papers
on electronics are published through
ieee
so they have a huge database
on anything from
microwave technology to
telephone transmission technology
anything that i might work with they
might have a white paper on it
also
with the audio engineering society aes i
uh
a member of that i lecture to aes
there's a few others but again
they're just mainly to have a repository
of information
have you received any honors or awards
yes i've received about 80 honors and
awards i have
for videography i've got a total of 12
emmy awards statues but i've been the
principal in 39 mb awards which means
i've written the music
for the program and and the program has
won
the emmy award for music but it was
given to the production company which
happens a lot i won for best editing i
won for best ace editing which is um
computer editing
uh
best sound
i've won
i've done the music to a piece that won
the gold lion at the cannes film
festival
i've done
music
to a piece that ran and won the gold at
the calgary film festival i've got a lot
of awards from associated press and
different
companies from doing documentaries and
news
have you published any works um in the
field of digital forensics
yes
and they're mostly articles about half
dozen numbers so we don't have much time
and i don't usually do it but it was
basically on most of my work deals
around clarifying or authenticating so
it was basically the things i published
were on clarification of digital files
have you appeared on tv as an expert in
digital forensics yes
where
cbs nbc abc
bbc
discovery channel a number of different
things any uh particular examples of
things that you've spoken on tv about
boston bombings how the frame averaging
was done on that sort of things like
that um again we get calls a lot but i
don't speak specifically about cases
i just speak about technology
have you given any public lectures in
the field of digital forensics yes we
get off as quite often but due to our
schedule it's a little rough we do
what's called ends of court we do
we speak in front of private
investigative groups
we do attorneys continuing legal
education
just
audio engineering society just
we try to do a few a year and that's
about what our schedules will allow
given our our
our time
your honor at this point i'd like to
tender mr newmeister as an expert in the
field of digital forensics any objection
no objection all right so moved
mr newmeister turning to the work you've
done in this case um what have you done
i was asked to analyze the photographs
or photographs of reported injuries to
misheard
and what was the purpose of that
analysis to authenticate photos or to uh
to review and see if they were
altered in any way
what did you analyze to to reach your
opinions well i analyzed groups of
photos that were submitted by uh
ms heard's legal team
what work did you do to analyze those
photographs well normally you start off
by looking at the what's called the exif
data the exit data is the binary data
that's encoded
into a photograph it tells you for
example
um
if the flash fired if that what the
operating software version was of the
cell phone for or camera that that shot
a photo
what type of lens was used what the
f-stop was there's literally about a
thousand lines of code in the exit data
on a jpeg photo so we would start with
an exif
editor or an xf viewer
anything else that you looked at yes um
when we're dealing with
rgb cameras which are red green and blue
channel cameras which would be a cell
phone or a basic home camera they're
based on rgb channels
we would do
four type four types of scopes we would
do a vector scope
we do we do a luminance scope we do a
waveform scope and then what's called an
rgb parade and those scopes analyze
different things
the
vector scope analyzes
where the different types of colors are
headed
in for example it's broken up into reds
magenta different
areas on a on a scope
we would um
we would take a look at that to see if
there's anything out of the normal for
the type of camera being used in other
words would there be
above a certain percentage of
chroma and chroma means color saturation
objection your honor um outside the
scope we can approach all right approach
mr newmeister based on the analysis you
performed in this case uh have you
formed any opinions
pardon me based on the analysis you've
done in this case have you formed any
opinions yes what are they
well three basic ones one is quite a
number of the photos have been through a
photo at least one possibly objection
your honor foundation which photos is he
referring to we have to go through this
one by one one's in evidence
uh mr
newmeister in terms of the photos that
you looked at and that you formed
opinions about
do you do you understand if they've been
submitted as evidence in this case yes
okay
and what conclusions have been formed
about those same objection your honor
that doesn't cure the issue of the
objection we have to go through this
which photos are she talking about which
one's in evidence what exhibit numbers
that's that's the basis of the
introduction generally about opinions
right now your honor and we're going to
get into some specifics i think that
goes straight to specifics okay
okay
um mr newmeister have you prepared a
demonstrative um that aids in your
testimony with respect to any of the
photos that you looked at in this case
yes
um i'd like to pull up plaintiff's 1303.
rather if i might approach all right
your honor i would
again object we can approach
tom can we pull up defendants exhibit
178 which has been admitted into
evidence
mr newmeister
um is this
does this photo appear to be one that
you have analyzed as part of your
analysis in this case there were many
versions of this photo um i would say
there were dozens of different versions
with different chromatic values
different file sizes different physical
sizes
some have been through photos one or
photos
three which are photo editing software
uh programs
um your honor at this time i'd like to
show mr mr newmeister's demonstrative
plaintiffs exhibit 1303. all right any
other objection i would object again
your honor because the photograph in
170a is not in evidence or yeah i mean
the photograph is in evidence the none
of the photographs use wishes to show
the jury earn evidence 1303
is an evidence over objection i'm not in
evidence i'm sorry it's a demonstrative
just as a demonstration i'm sorry
the publishing is very pleased
and mr newmeister what is this
demonstrative show about the photos that
you analyzed
well the the appear to be
similar however if you look below at the
file sizes
one on the left is 712 kilobytes
the one in the middle is 489 kilobytes
and the one on the right is 524
kilobytes now what's unusual about that
is these photos will not digitally
fingerprint with each other they won't
hash in other words forensically they
don't match
but
the thing is you could say well it was
sent through email maybe it's a
different size
this the file sizes
for example would be
possibly
you know you can select the file size
you send a photo
but there's no way to authenticate any
photo that was presented in the way the
evidence was collected
and so what conclusions do you draw from
that well there's this is just three of
many of the same type of photos that are
all different sizes and have different
chromatic which means connection your
honor we just had a ruling on this
all right sustained injection mr
investor stick to your opinions that
relate specifically to what you analyzed
about the exif data please all three of
these photos had to go through some type
of transformation to change sizes
we can take that one down
you mentioned
photos 1.5 in photos 3.0 earlier i
believe
photos what is that photos 3 and photos
1.5 are editing programs that
macintosh or apple put out with their
product
it's for editing photos in other words
you would put a photo in
and you would change the colors or you
would crop it or you would clarify it by
enhancing for example the sharpening
or you could darken it
but when you save a photo through an
editing program you leave a mark on the
exif data
and what is the exif data the exit data
is the data that is embedded in a
photograph that tells you a lot about
the photograph and again in the early
days when we were using film cameras you
would write down the f-stop which is the
light setting you would you would write
the type of lens you use
the time of day
the type of film stock the type of
filters you're using
now with digital cameras
uh
that's done electronically
and there's about
about a thousand lines of code of which
50 are probably important that tell you
what the camera was doing
so what's the significance of exif data
in your photo analysis well in this
situation i can see that normally
where the operating system of the camera
would be which means the version that
the
operating system the phone is running on
it would normally say something like
i'll just throw out an arbitrary number
9.1.3 operating system for ios which is
apple's iphone operating system
instead of saying that it says software
photos 3.0 or photos 1.0 that means that
the photo had to be rendered
which means composited together in an
editing program
did you prepare a demonstrative that
shows uh some of your analysis of some
of the exit data of the photos in this
case yes i do okay can we pull up 1304
please your honor may i approach
are you okay
permission to publish as a demonstration
of your honor any any objection
any objection sorry honor she was used
to publish it as a demonstration
no objectives demonstrated all right
thank you we'll publish it as 1304
just as a democrat
and mr newmeister are these images in
this demonstrative excerpts from the
report you prepared in this case yes
and what do they show
on this particular photo and and on all
of them it shows the first few lines of
exif data the ones that would be most
important for this photograph
so for example things you would see the
very top line would be the make of a
phone it's an apple
iphone
6
and then the resolution is 72 pixels per
inch 72 to 1.
um
and instead where it says software on a
normal iphone photo it would instead of
saying photos 3
it would say uh the software version for
example 9.3.1
and then you've got the date and the
time of the photo
uh below that which is really easy to
change in an exif editor and below that
you have uh
things like the exact
like the flash you've got um
the exposure type how long the exposure
was
uh so what you just highlighted there
again was the date and time
uh so
that's uh universal time code minus
whatever area you're in in the world
anything else you want to show us with
this demonstrative uh yeah just below
that if you look up there's some
things that would say for example a
directly photographed image that is not
going to be necessarily accurate once
it's been through an editor it will
always pretty much say that
so
when you're looking at scene scene type
or auto exposure
these are things that that really don't
matter all that much what would matter
is
for example
if you're taking notes the focal length
would be important
the pattern of metering
things like that to a photographer would
be would be important
and again this is just a few lines and
the reason i put these in there was just
to explain a bit what
exif data is
uh the actual thing i'm trying to point
out is the fact that instead of an
operating system it shows
the um
the editing program that was used on
this photo
um are there additional photos that you
did this analysis for yes many okay
um can we scroll to the next page please
tom
is there anything um about this photo
that you noted as part of your analysis
mr newmeister yes again it's it's uh
you know right right there you've got
photos 3.0 on that particular photo
and i think you know we pretty much
covered what what the stuff is but again
you see the
photos 3.0
and again this could not come out of an
iphone this way this would go into a
computer be edited
and rendered through the photo uh
editing photo editor and this would then
be embedded in the exif data
do you have other photos in this
demonstrative yes all right can we
scroll to the next page
uh same thing
you've got up here in the up top you've
got the uh the photos 3.0 and this is uh
throughout a lot of the photos that are
in evidence or versions of the photos
and evidence were gone through photos
3.0 or photos 1.5 an earlier version
let me scroll to the next
page play store
and what about this one
same thing photos 3.0 and again in a
photo editing app you can do an awful
lot of things so when you see photos 3.0
first of all you know it's not
anywhere near an original there's going
to be compression artifacts
because it's a jpeg file
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question can we move on to the next
page of this demonstrative police
and again same thing
you've got the photos
app
okay
and i believe there's one final photo in
this
demonstrative what about this one
again if you look up there it says
photos 3.0
on that particular photo
all right we can take that one down
your honor i had a little bit left i
don't know if you wanted to all right
you want to take our afternoon let's go
ahead and take our afternoon recess
just uh do not discuss the case and
don't do any outside reach outside
research thank you
so
right so let's let's just come back at
four o'clock all right
may we approach one moment okay
all right
yes your honor sorry i'm sorry
thanks man
hmm
all right
okay you can be seated your next
question
thank you
mr newmeister do you have another
demonstrative prepared um that shows a
photo with exif data reflecting that it
was saved in photos three
correct
photos three yes
um your honor we have a video of um
these photos and we're happy to play it
once so that council can review
if that's all right
okay
okay
so
uh
all right we took care of that your
honor thank you may we publish or would
you like to see it
okay
and what's what's demonstrative is this
going to be then this is plaintiff's
1305 your honor thank you
could you play it
subject to your honor as well you guys
know
all right so 130 marked as plaintiff
1305 and new system monsters so you can
publish the jury
mr newmeister we're going to
go ahead and play the demonstrative that
you prepared and then after the jury's
had a chance to see it if you want to
explain to them what the demonstrator
shows that would be great yes ma'am
can you publish
so mr newmeister what was depicted in
that video
the same photo treated two different
ways one was marked with the original
opera or with the operating system from
an iphone which is ios 9.3.1 on that
particular
photo the one that says 9.3.1 there is a
graphic below indicating it
the second photo uh is marked photos
three and it looks quite a bit different
and um just tom could we pull up
defendant 708
mr newmeister does the image in
defendant 708 appear to be uh similar
the same photo as uh what was depicted
in your demonstrative it's the
it's actually is the photos 3.0 uh
edit version
thank you we can take that one down tom
mr newmeister have you also formed an
opinion about defendants exhibit 712 and
713 correct
um did you prepare demonstrative that
shows
i can show you if you'd like
all right could we pull up um
plaintiff's exhibit 1306 tom
and your honor this is another video
that oh can you pause that please
this is another video that we prepared
it's not published yet so i'm happy to
play it once through um
what uh exhibits are these that are in
this video it doesn't say i don't know
yeah i tried to get my question out a
moment ago defendant 7 12 and 7 13 your
honor
okay 1306 then we'll be at the launch
and if we could go ahead and play that
please
tom
and mr newmeister um what's your um
what do we see here in this
demonstration
um
there's uh
exhibit 7 12 i believe you have i'm not
sure the debate's number 712 and 7 13.
uh there are two separate exhibits
except it's the exact same photograph
that's been
uh one's been edited one hasn't or i
can't say that one hasn't but
uh the colors have been uh modified in
an editor objection your honor uh beyond
the scope of your ruling talking about
colors
it keeps happening
thank you
um mr newmeister um
did you form an opinion in this case
about the authenticity of the photos
that you were
reviewed of misheard
well
first of all you can't i can't nobody
can identify
the authenticity of the photos of any of
the photos
marked
photos three photos one or just marked
with the
operating system number and the reason
is the manner of collection
so these came from an itunes backup now
what is an itunes backup
it's actually your honor i'm sorry
you're on the scope you're ruling exit
metadata this keeps happening
new york may approach on this one
so mr newmeister
without going into the specifics what's
your opinion about the authenticity of
the photos you received from mishard
based on the way they were collected
there would be objection your honor we
just ruled on this
i framed my question about your honor to
avoid the issue that you're concerned
about mr newmeister what's your opinion
about the authenticity here there's no
way for any forensic expert to validate
any of these photos thank you very much
no further questions
good afternoon mr newmeister good
afternoon
your only degree is in political science
correct
42 years ago correct
and you have no degree whatsoever from
any academic institution in computer
science correct
that's correct
and you have no certifications in
computer forensics correct that's
correct
from the opinions you've testified today
you relied on no data except for the
embedded exif metadata to support those
opinions correct incorrect
what other data did you rely on for the
opinions you testified to today i was
trying to explain that you kept it what
other data did you rely on for the
actual opinions you've been able to
testify to today besides exif metadata
the type of extraction that was
performed
you're asking the question for the
actual opinions you you testify to
that is what i would use i also use
vector scopes objection your honor
that's that was not responsive to my
question your honor if you want to
approach
so you can answer that
question you can answer the question
can you restate the question
uh
i don't recall a question your honor we
can move on your honor maybe we could
have the court reporter read it back
they could redirect
but now what was the question
judy
i believe the question was what
methodology did i use to
make my findings judy's voice has
changed that's
sorry is that correct judy
okay
that's fine
okay
so
when you're analyzing video or photo in
this objection to video your honor
that's beyond the scope
all right if you could just answer the
question sir
when you're
analyzing a photo
a digital photo
you look at the exif data
you use a vector scope
you can use a pantone chart if that's
available and that should be done but
that's a whole different deal if i go
into that you'll object to it
so you'd also use
a waveform scope
you would use
an rgb parade
you can use a histogram though in this
case it's not really all that relevant
you are not offering any opinions that
any photo back photograph in this case
was intentionally modified by miss her
correct
i'm just stating the fact that
photographs were modified but so you are
not offering any opinion that any
photograph in this case was
intentionally modified by ms heard
correct
that's correct
can you please pull up exhibit 170a
is that defendant's one second
defendants 170 yes your honor
so you offer testimony regarding this
photograph during the direct examination
right mr newmeister there's that that's
a yes or no sir
the photograph like that i don't exactly
remember the uh photograph there's so
many different versions of this
photograph but yes i talked about that
particular photograph but on uh do you
recall being deposed in this matter yes
you were under oath yes that was on
april 6 2022
i believe
i approach yes sir
thank you
so mr newmeister if you could please
turn to page
76
and when i say pages those are the
little pages and the four boxes not on
the page at the top
and you see page 76 line three
you were asked on april 6 anywhere in
your april 1st 2022 expert disclosure do
you offer any opinions regarding the
authenticity or lack of authenticity of
the specific photograph produced as alh
7101 response can i refer to my report
to see if that specific number is in the
report
yes response not that specific photo i
just grabbed three out of the batch do
you see that yes
can you please pull up exhibit 517
or defendants 517. thank you
you are not offering any opinions
regarding the specific photograph right
mr newmeister that's correct my
testimony has been limited here
and you are not offering any opinion
that any photograph was visually
doctored by amber correct not by i can't
put the person
who might have done it
well you're not offering an opinion that
a photo was visually doctored by anybody
are you
i'd have to see each photo there's no
way to authenticate any of these photos
based on what i received
so you testified about photos 3 do you
recall that testimony correct
photos 3 is a photo editing and photo
sorting application correct
it's a photo editor in photoshop as is
our number of editors
so when you reference photos 3.0 you
never did any independent res um strike
that your honor
so when the when the software of a
photograph in the exif metadata says
photos 3.0 that could be just saying
that the photo was saved in photos 3.0
correct
unless you looked at a scope of the
photos that would tell you that the
parameters of the photo do not meet that
of the cell phone that it was taken on
but the notation photos 3.0 and the
software exif metadata that does not in
and of itself mean that the photo was
edited in photos 3.0 correct it means
that you've recompressed the photo and
it will not hash or digitally
fingerprint with the original photo but
it does not mean in and of itself that
it was visually edited in any way in
photos 3.0 correct
again it's not the same photo because
you're using lossy compression once you
save it so it you have changed the photo
so if you could please turn to page 233
of that transcript
and
line 20 do you see question when it says
exit software okay photos 3.0
onto 234 that's just saying it was saved
in photos 3.0 right response saved in
3.0 that's correct
question that notation in and of itself
does not mean that the photo was edited
in 3.0 right answer that's correct did i
read that correctly yes
a file has not changed visually just
because it has been processed through
photos 3.0 correct that's incorrect
can you look at page 128 of your
deposition please
at the bottom line 20 questions you see
question but the file changed visually
just because it is it has been processed
through photos 3.0
answer you know obviously i understand
what you're asking from a technical
point yes because of the compression you
get down to scopes and artifacts yes it
has changed was it intentionally changed
we don't know in other words did
somebody save it in there and just save
the photo we don't know did i read that
correctly that's correct
but again it says that was my question
mr newmeister okay
so if the exif metadata software field
lists the software as ios
you have no reason to dispute that
correct incorrect well isn't data data
that's what you testify to right it's
very simple to modify xf data
it's i mean did you find any evidence in
this case of actual modification of exif
metadata
you can't
you can't authenticate any of these
photos because of the way they were that
wasn't my question mr newmeister did you
find any evidence of any modification of
exif metadata of any photograph in this
case you didn't listen to my answer my
answer is there is no way to know
because of the way the files were
presented
so you felt but you actually you found
no actual evidence of it correct that no
one could i'm not aware anyone else
could mr newmeister i'm asking dude you
yourself find you you found no evidence
of any modification of exif metadata of
any photograph in this case correct now
i understand trying to control the
narrative but there's no way to answer
that scientifically because
given the evidence we're given there is
no way to positively or negatively
answer that it's not a question that can
be answered it is a question mr
newmeister the question is did you
yourself
you found no affirmative evidence of any
modification of software exit metadata
of any photograph in this case correct
you you found no actual evidence of that
did you
no one could tell either way because i
asked you about anyone else missionaries
i'm asking about you
did you you found no evidence of that
did you objection your honor asked and
answered
he's not answered what he found here
overruled
there's not a way to answer that the way
you're asking the question you have to
restate it and you're trying to your
honor he's not responding to the
question can you just answer yes or no
sir to the question
it's not a yes or no question did you
yes or no
you found you found no
evidence of exif metadata modification
of any photograph in this case correct
that's incorrect
okay
it is your opinion that the metadata of
all photographs of purported injuries
that misheard has identified as her
trial exhibits do not indicate that the
photographs went through a photo editing
application correct
well
first of all
that's not a yes or no question because
a lot of the exhibits that you have
put up
they're not photographs
they're screen grabs and they've been
changed from
apple format which is jpeg
jpeg
to a jpg microsoft format so you have
actually changed the exemplars you've
changed the data yourselves
we actually ran
uh exif data on some of your own
examples that you've entered in the
evidence they are not photos from an
iphone those were edited in a pc
i'm going to
hand up a page from your disclosure
so
disclosures
yes sir
thank you
thank you
so do you see on page 80 your disclosure
mr newmeister
it states quote
the metadata of all of the photographs
of purported injuries that misheard has
identified as her trial exhibits do not
indicate that the photographs went
through a photo editing application did
i read that correct that's correct
we're talking no further questions all
right redirect
mr newmeister um a moment ago mr murphy
was asking you some questions about your
opinion about the trial exhibits that ms
heard is offered in this matter
um
and he asked you about your opinion that
they don't indicate that they've gone
through a photo editing application what
can you tell us about that well first of
all in this last exhibit it says
metadata not exif data so that's two
different things all together we're
talking exif data and on a report i put
metadata because i was requested to
cover meta and exit data so it's taken
out of context the exit data is the data
based
that's embedded in the photo metadata
can be the file data about the file
itself two different things
so
the way the data was collected
it was
an itunes backup
is a backup
objection your honor backups outside the
scope your honors ruling beyond exit
metadata i think you open the door and
the overall
an itunes backup is
only a backup of things that are on an
iphone that have not been deleted it
does not have the critical operating
system it doesn't have any of the files
that would validate the path of a
photograph
in that phone it does not have a lot of
the log files it does not have the
knowledge c database which talks about
usage of the phone and
the patterns of how data was handled
all it is is the photos you just decided
to save
not
the photos you deleted so it's a very
limited database
without the system registry or without
the system operating system there's no
way to tell because it's very easy to
modify a photo on a phone and have it
just read ios 9.3.1
but with the actual phone if you were
able to
get a hold of the actual phone
and in 95 of all cases we work we have
the actual phones it doesn't matter if
the phones are 10 years old or 20 years
old or
20 years old but 10 years old
the reason is if people have something
they want to keep as evidence they don't
throw out their phones they don't
recycle their phones they save their
phones
people
ask how we're doing phones on 13 year
old cases because people do not throw
out
evidence
they keep the phone
so in a situation like this there are no
forensic extractions in fact the
extractions we were provided
were backups
of backups
of itunes
just exports so it's third generation
and there is no way to verify the file
paths and the history of any single
photo that we've looked at
further questions your honor all right
thank you sir you can have a seat in the
courtroom where you're free to go thank
you very much all right your next
witness
we call morgan excuse me
beverly leonard
by video link i need the tv all right
just give us a moment to get the tv up
you